e
thank you for being here uh it is now
10:01 I'm going to call this meeting to
order and I would like to ask
representative grer if she'd like to
thank you everyone I'm just going to
read our
mission this bipartisan committee is
tasked with investigating and evaluating
the state's response to the covid-19
pandemic the committee will function in
a science-based fact finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data in all related information
pertaining there too areas of particular
Focus will include the administration of
federal guidance acceptance of federal
funds and implementation of emergency
use authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings in the impact on
New Hampshire today uh we have opened up
uh for Citizens for the from the state
of New Hampshire to address this
committee and I would like to call
well I didn't I'm representing Timothy
Horan from straford County District 10
which is the town of Durham as probably
everyone around the table knows um I was
ough I feel a little bit silly since
only two people showed up but I guess uh
we're here so um so guess the first
thing I going to say the we hear a lot
about other aspects of the the covid
emergency but the covid-19 virus itself
was and still is the deadliest
respiratory virus in human history so I
say is because it's still out there and
it's still being spread around it's
mutated into a less deadly form than it
was four years ago but it's still there
and the various interventions we tried
here in the United States and worldwide
to stop the virus they weren't all 100%
safe or 100% effective but they were
necessary and they they mostly worked is
um and uh I predicted we're going to
hear a lot of talk about rights
expecting a larger crowd but anyway
there is no natural or inherent right to
spread a respiratory virus um there is
however a natural and inherent right to
breathe in any case um I just want to
remind you of a few facts and you've
seen these before but according to the
CDC as April 27th 2024 the total death
toll from Co United States was 1,1
190,220
official death toll was
3,516 including um the Speaker of the
House dick hinch and um at the height of
the pandemic in January 2021 the death
rate from Co no wise 78 7.8 per 100,000
or one person per
12,850 so uh in I'm not sure which New
Hampshire Community is Clos to
12,850 but um you know that was one
person was dying every week amongst any
group of people of that size
and and
um two thing one thing I mentioned is
the uh that death to I just cited which
is probably little
understated um is about equivalent to
the losing the entire population of New
Hampshire so like if everybody in the
state died obviously that's a pretty
tremendous catastrophe and they um but
that's that's how many people died um
and just in the state is equivalent to
losing the entire population of the town
of Chesterfield um so this is the word
really the worst catastrophe in American
history with the exception of the Civil
War and we got off easier both other
countries and the the pandemic was was
pretty B and it could have been easily
been even worse um so the three most
controversial inventions I think were
all um mostly successful Which social
distancing that was painful so I'm glad
that we're meeting and person in but it
worked and some of the hastily arranged
workarounds we came up with such as um
holding meetings we resumed are still
used today even you know four years
later after we've all pretty much
pretended that Co is not there
anymore The Masks were uncomfortable in
my case I always made my glasses fogged
up but they worked you know not
perfectly but they
worked the vaccines also worked um the V
they've been blamed for just about every
Health Emergency suffered by any
individual anywhere in the planet since
they were introduced back in early
2021 however the relevant Public Health
Data shows that those vaccines were safe
and effective not 100% safe not 100%
effective but I I believe they but I'm I
know that they they did work so that's
uh so that's my testimony I'm actually
in um I think I'm probably in pretty
close to the three minutes so oh I'm not
limiting you to three yes we're not in
any hurry we got all but um but will you
take questions sure I guess so yes does
anyone have a question for
representative orgon oh good uh
representative beler
please thank you mam chair and thank you
uh representative for being here um you
did note that there is no inherent right
for people to spread a respiratory virus
so when a right is violated that creates
a cause of action for somebody so are
you suggesting that if somebody were to
come into work with the flu or the
common cold and spread that virus that
they should be subject to some s of a
lawsuit or criminal punishment for doing
so well I'm that's a hypothetical
question which uh I'll uh pivot a little
little bit into saying that the mass
also actually reduced the incidence of
seasonal flu and the common cold and the
seasonal flu in particular um we tend to
take it for granted but that's a major
public health issue and we haven't had a
you know we we have we have a seasonal
flu uh epidemics almost almost every
year but the ones that we've had over
the last four years have been much uh
milder especially in 21 and 22 and that
was partially because people were
wearing masks and of course in 21 and it
less in 2022 they weren't gathering in
in groups as much so those um I mean as
for whether there's lawsuits and stuff I
don't want to get into that but yeah
thanks uh
followup thank you Madame chair uh yes I
I just want to dig a little deeper into
that because the idea of spreading
viruses being a potential something
that's not inherent right for people
there is some precedent in law for that
multiple places in the country for
instance via uh they've criminalized
knowingly spreading the HIV virus now
some places like California have
recently worked to decriminalized that
on various different ideological reasons
but are you suggesting that if if there
is no inherent right to be able to
spread a respiratory virus that we
should take measures similar to places
have done with HIV and criminalize the
spreading of respiratory viruses or or
creating a civil um cause of action for
people to sue over we're we're not the
special committee on HIV response
efficacy although that was a problem in
New Hampshire and everywhere else um res
you know sexual sexually transmitted
virus that's very serious but a
respiratory that's an even more basic
bodily function so it's pretty much uh
pretty much unavoidable if you stop if
you stop breathing you die within a few
minutes so that's uh you know that's not
that a sexually transmitted virus isn't
serious but like a respiratory virus
that's that's like even more serious and
even more basic to functioning so um as
for the rest of it you know we can we
can convene a special committee on the
HIV response although HIV sort of we we
we got some treatments at work somewhat
and some vaccines work somewhat and
we've pretty much uh forgotten forgotten
that it happened so thanks uh
representative
weary thank you madam chair and thank
you representative Horan for taking my
questions um at the bottom of your
testimony you make uh several assertions
three all
right I ah there it goes all right um
thank you um well thank you madam chair
for uh and representative Horan for
taking my question um at the bottom of
your written testimony you make
assertions with regard to the E efficacy
or effectiveness of
uh three interventions
there
assertions well that's that's my mostly
it's my opinion as a not totally
well-informed but reasonbly
well-informed citizen um I you know I
was a member of the House back in 2020
and there were a number of uh you know
there were a number of uh number of
series of briefings some public some
like a little bit less so certain with
the vaccine um the Public Health
Community did try to brief uh you know
interested interested parties including
public officials so I did get kind of a
I'm not a virologist or an
epidemiologist but I got some somewhat
um you know I did hear like almost every
week about what was going on and of
course I also watched the same televised
briefings anybody could watch I that was
pretty much all I did during that's
pretty much all I did for a couple of
months back in 2020 when I was stuck at
home and there wasn't much else to do
you know I and course sometimes I wonder
why some of those officials how they had
time to do their jobs they're spending
so much time on TV including uh you
including governor cunu and uh
commissioner shet you know they were on
for like an hour every day and it was
good TV but still wonder like I was
amazed they had time to do their job so
I um I'll just say that's my opinion
based on based on what's out there and
I'm sure when you issue your report
there'll be varying opinions on it so
that's I don't know that's the answer
uh forgive me but as an engineer and as
someone who has worked in the healthcare
industry for 40 years I just want to
make sure that I understand um have is
there any scientific or technical
evidence that you can present to
substantiate these assertions
oh that wasn't
uh the the the data exists I was just
here to issue my one page opinion and
speak for three minutes and then answer
questions so that's uh you know there's
other experts you can call in if you
want to if you want to call them in so
that's uh wish I had a better answer for
you but that's uh I I will say I work
with Vital Records a lot and there were
like more deaths than there should have
been and there weren't more deaths from
respiratory disease than there normally
should have been During the period from
going back to 2020 and continuing even
today so I I can't tell you um I can
tell so that's one area I have a little
bit more expertise the average person
not as much as I should so certainly if
you like just at that particular realm
of data yes there are quite a few excess
deaths in fact I think in 2021 the
average life expect of Americans
actually went down and it was wasn't
wasn't due to a wasn't due to the mass
or the vaccines or any so thank uh
represent
cran I I just wanted to jump into this I
mean we've um had a few other meetings
where we've had experts testify at
length to the efficacy of the vaccines
there's thousands and thousands of uh
you know scientific peer-reviewed
Publications that have shown this at
this point um I'm not sure it's
appropriate to be asking our testifier
to uh come up with all that support
we've we've heard it from other
folks thank you and represent groa
thank you I want to I would like to
thank you for coming and sharing your
thoughts and I do want to remind
everyone that this is a public comment
meeting and it's not meant to be um
questioning
or
um
cross-examining our the people that come
before us and I appreciate your thoughts
and I would appreciate and I appreciate
everyone who comes and speaks before us
so thank you so much well thank you and
you're welcome and thank you
representative broa for stating that
fact I appreciate that
um if there's any other questions and
representative Horgan thank you so much
for coming and uh presenting your
testimony and sharing with us your
thoughts hopefully hopefully it helped a
little bit thanks I appreciate it
okay um The Honorable uh Betty gay would
okay Betty gay from
Salem excuse
me um I have to apologize I just learned
about your committee night before last
so I've been trying to remember the many
many things that were on my mind when we
were going through this and so my notes
are not in order I really meant to put
them in order and also to bring some
written uh some the documentation where
I where I got these opinions some of it
is just personally observed others were
things that I read um and my
concern I I have actually many many
concerns I really believe strongly that
we if we are faced with another
situation like we had to deal with covid
that we will open the lines of
communication so that every body is
listened to and not ridiculed those
people who had shared a lot of my
opinions were shut down we absolutely
could not ever hear on national news
what we had learned through study
finding uh finding studies that were
being done listening to doctors who were
actually treating patients uh for whom
it was not theoretical if they didn't do
the right thing they lost their patience
and it was really wrenching and uh some
of them were ICU doctors and they had to
face this on a daily
basis um they had to invent new ways of
treatment and just yesterday I was
reading another uh listening to another
video that is posted by Dr John Campbell
of England he is fascinating person he
is retired he was a teacher of nurses
and he uh zooms with people from oh
Australia New
Zealand New
Orleans New York so uh are people like
Dr moin Sayad Dr Bean he's another
person who's uh actually he's a
businessman as well as a a person who
treats people and he's created uh a like
a medical school refresher course for
people for a very modest fee for like
$75 you can have uh a membership and
look up anything and he does all these
drawings I mean the guy is a genius and
I really appreciate that he gets other
people on there so you're not just
listening to him like Dr Paul oh well
here's my apology I don't have this all
in order it's like a patchwork quilt so
I'll just keep giving you things if it's
interesting you can say I'm going to ask
her she has to document this but uh like
I said I really intended to bring the
paper that I put together a couple of
years ago so that you could look it up
for yourself and make up your own mind
about the results um I'll see if I can
read my some of my
notes the overall conclusion I came to
was that the next time a communicable
disease is identified in New Hampshire I
want to see medically responsible
interventions to be practiced the
unscientific methods applied last time
caused thousands of susceptible people
to die now that's a pretty serious
accusation they were either frail or
deficient in immunity they could have
been hail and Hearty but like I saw one
man interviewed on TV he was a nurse he
was black he was in a Southern state and
he was documenting day by day his his
fighting the illness well I found out
later through my reading one of the
things that was against him otherwise he
was hail and Hearty he's likely very low
in vitamin D the darker your skin the
less likely you are to absorb sunshine
and make vitamin D vitamin D is a really
hot topic because it used to be that 30
nanograms per milliliter was considered
very high you didn't want to go above
that but somebody in um in U it's it was
in Asia and despite the real impact of
the study they did I had a really hard
time finding out where they did the
study but this person went to four
hospitals in their area so that they
could find 50 patients who had very
light cases and I assume that was in
Asia because in Asia they're much more
likely to put you in the hospital for
something you could do at home in Japan
they don't even want to send you home if
you're on crutches if they know you're
by yourself so it's different attitude
from the way we we handle people and
assume people can be self-sufficient so
anyway they found 50 patients who were
very had very mild cases 50 cases of
people who were at risk of dying they
were so sick and then 50 Paces people in
in between the two and they measured
their vitamin D level guess what the
people who were extremely ill had less
than 20 n
meas tested at less than 20 nanog per
milliliter of vitamin D3 in their
bloodstream the people who had extremely
light cases measured over 30 and the
people in between was
proportional it's not
100% but it's pre you know 90% it was it
was really
convincing and so I got really
interested in studying vitamin D and
there's a huge range of what people
think is appropriate some people think
the high number that you shouldn't go
over is a 100 nanograms per milliliter
So I myself took enough it doesn't
matter how much you take it's how much
your blood has in it so um the only way
to do that is to be tested so when
people say oh I take so and so and they
think that's it no you really really
need to test it if you're if you're
aiming at a healthy goal um one of the
things that was just amazing I
accidentally picked up a newspaper that
had been sent to me uh thinking it was a
local one it turns out it was one from a
a company that's famous for its
nutritional studies and and selling
nutritional things
um breast cancer is known as the low
D oh low D
illness and that's was confirmed to me
by other people friends of mine who've
been fighting breast cancer for many
years and this article confirmed it it
said that people whose blood level was
over 65 nanograms per milliliter their
uh their percentage I'm not sure how to
say this the their risk of developing
my husband who is a re cancer survivor
of um salivary gland cancer I said hun
do you want to read this article he said
no I'll just take the
d so it's really easy you know it comes
in really little bitty pills and through
some of the studies that I can can send
you when I find it in my pile of papers
in my office um they found that
um
D2 you can also take D2 because our body
can changes it from the time it makes it
from the sunshine on our skin it goes
through multiple conversions and if you
take the D3 you're the closest you can
take it that's quickly quickly used by
the body if you take D2 your body has to
convert it to D3 first so it delays it
another day or two uh but it's all
inexpensive incredibly inexpensive and
Tiny little pills you can get them in
oilbased pills you can get them in in
solid cat solid pills so um I've been
trying to gently tell people if that's
an option they want it's really easy to
inexpensive they found in um Spain and
in France I found articles about a one U
Nursing Home in each published an
article
they've heard about D being protective
well nursing home people are pretty
frail and so that you know I'm glad they
were trying to be proactive to Pro
protect their people so they gave them
and they call it Bolis I guess when you
do a Bolis any kind of thing it's a pill
it's we're giving instead of in your
food on a regular basis it's we're going
to give you a a
dosage and uh
they found that the people that they
gave it to their statistics even though
that we're talking about small numbers
you know statistics should be in the
thousands they're talking about who's in
their nursing home it was profound
nobody they gave the D2 had to go to the
hospital nobody and their time that they
were ill if they were ill was very
shortened and not not
life-threatening okay so all these
studies that came out the only way I
found them was looking them up online I
never saw anything like this on the news
on the news we knew counts the number of
people then we found out later many
months later that the hospitals knew
that they got a lot more reimbursement
for treating people if they were being
I'll just say what I'll identify the
elephant in the room lots of people were
diagnosed as having covid who didn't
have it and I've Heard lots of people
who worked in the hospitals say that so
I really this is my opinion I really as
a scientist I only have one degree it's
in chemistry so I took biology and
chemistry and physics and don't test me
right now because it was quite a while
ago but it means it means that I was
trained in the scientific method and you
don't just take the word for somebody
because they observed something
happening that could be out on uh three
standard deviations out uh that could be
you you want to see enough data to draw
conclusion that that the cause really
did tie to the effect but when people
are dying of an illness and you have
people who who are getting very mildly
ill or not ill at all to me that needs
to be
investigated but we didn't see any I
didn't see anything in the news that
said anybody was investigating this in
India after oh let's see I I have to
back
up um in I can't remember if it was 19
2020 or
2021 that somebody thought to check
icton it's an old medicine
1970s it was uh developed to treat um as
a substitute for Chlor
chloroquin which was then refined in the
1930s to hydroxy
chloroquin which is to sell to to kill
parasites either to kill them or to
prevent them from taking over in your
body um the most famous one of course is
malaria but uh in the 1970s ircon was
delivered deliberately studied to try to
kill river blindness because where
people live where the water is dirty
that's a very common cause of blindness
and uh preventing it finally in
2015 won the Nobel Prize
meanwhile after we learned that uh Dr
Pierre Corey and Dr Paul marrick m a r i
k um Dr Corey is from the US Dr Merrick
is a US practicing ICU doctor just like
Dr Corey is but uh by his accent I'm
going to guess he's from South
Africa they heard about Ivor mechon
being used in a test tube well what
could kill the covid was higher con
concentrations than what people could
tolerate but people take icton all the
time when if they have a a skin let's
see what is that
called um I I listened to and watched on
a video a doctor uh in
Toronto who was uh learned about she has
her own I'm sorry I'm such a rotten
speaker I do my best but it's not good
um you're doing fine okay okay thank you
uh she heard about this amazing thing
that happened in a Toronto nursing home
it was a really big one it had four four
floors and they had an outbreak of and I
cannot remember the name of it but it's
a
skin it affects the skin and it is a
parasite so they treated all the people
with Ivor and that's what it's it's for
parasites and then to PE just to
hopefully stop it from spreading to the
other floors they gave lower dosages to
everybody not the staff the people who
live there then some staff person
brought in
covid guess who got
sick the staff guess who didn't get
sick none of the
residents don't you think that's
newsworthy
they did their best to call the TV
stations the radio stations and offer to
be interviewed because it was so
profound who came and interviewed
them no
criminal that's another elephant in the
room you're not supposed to say anybody
did anything deliberately
wrong but that was so Earth
shattering and one one of one of my
friends who died early on was in his 80s
he was frail he was never offered
anything no
hydroxychloroquine no iorc well they
didn't even know about Ivermectin early
on but
uh the other well I can go on for for
another couple of minutes um the
flccc
Frontline covid Critical Care aliance
was founded by Dr Corey and Dr Merrick
and some other Brave doctors who signed
on and uh they were actually treating
patients and of course they didn't get
patients until they were deafly ill
because they they treat in ICU so
anybody they are able to save was was
remarkable um they were repeating they
their work was repeated by a doctor in
Pennsylvania uh they had a woman who was
hanging on to dear life on a respirator
for days and her family heard about iron
so they asked the doctors to give it to
her they said no we don't know about it
we're not going to use it they went to
court luckily they were able to get a
court hearing within a day the judge
said give it to her they
did they gave it to her one day the next
day she was off the rest spirator
sitting in a chair next to her
bed now if that's not newsworthy I don't
know what is so then she was better so
she didn't need to stay in the ICU so
they transferred her to another part of
the
hospital they said keep giving her ior
mechon the doctor said no I don't
believe in it again they had to go to
court and force him to give it to her
and she did recover and she did go home
the same thing happened in New York but
how many people number one had the
information cuz it wasn't in the news
and how many people have the wherewithal
to go to court and pay for it and find
an attorney and get a judge who is
choice in India when they learned about
the
iveron most of the states India has
several States I have no idea I have no
memory of how many but they have many
states so each state makes up their own
mind so the person who is head of the
National Health whatever agency that's
called recommended the icton so all
states but one gave it out for free to
their
people the incidents of Co dropped the
one state that didn't it didn't
drop then the person who was in charge
National Ally left and a new person came
in who was listening to the popular
opinion she banned it can't give it out
anymore so the co incidents climbed
right back fortunately somebody said we
can't do this anymore and overruled her
and again they were able to suppress
suppress the
outbreak I heard man a man who was
visiting different hospitals in
different
countries he went to
Brazil and he was used to going to
hospitals and seeing how how they were
treating their covid patients you know
what what's the report from them so he
went to one and he said he wanted to go
to the co Ward and they looked kind of a
scance and he finally found out they
didn't have one they were giving out ior
mecon and they had no patience
at
all so despite this really great success
that was experienced in several places
it was not carried on the public news
you had to find it by looking for it I
find that absolutely
reprehensible this sounds like the
people were listening to some very
guidelines and again I'm going to say
this is my guess I don't want to say
this
absolutely but the same people who made
REM Des which had been developed to
treat Ebola and didn't work well so they
lost a lot of money it costs a fortune
to create a drug and to test it it is
really really a deterrent and that's why
it's a deterrent to FDA accepting new
medicines because you really have to be
a huge Company to pay for what it t it
takes to get
approval so uh some of the really good
medicines are not FDA approved because
they've been uh recognized and found by
companies that don't have that kind of
money they're doing studies on else
arene over at Dartmouth Hitchcock for
treating neuronal diseases and they need
to find somebody who can put the money
up for the second and third tiers of
testing which has wonderful
opportunities for ALS and uh somewhat to
alzheimer's but that's another story but
that just shows you that we really need
to come up with rules that allow people
give people the right to try medications
and sad ly that was only a
presidential um edict what is the
term executive order yeah we really need
that to be a law maybe that is but I
hadn't heard that it passed
um I was really really
upset I guess it's doesn't matter what
my emotions were but I thought it was
absolutely wrong that not only were
these success stories not
publicized the medicines were accused
the people who proposed using the
medicines were
ridiculed massive amounts of news were
spent to deny the legitimacy of their
work and to deny people the right to try
I called every Pharmacy that I could
find listed so I started with the
pharmacies that are national
um you know the chains the CVS The Ride
Aid the
Walgreens um I called everybody then I
called the individual uh privately owned
ones to find out how to get
iant every one of them said you can't
get it unless your doctor says it's for
parasite
treatment if they say it's for
um if they say it's for covid we can't
fill
it now the CDC has finally been found
against by a federal court that said you
can't do that you can't make up you
can't decide how people are
treated but that was in effect for a
couple of years the only way you could
get ior macton was to buy it from
another country
um do you mind if I ask you a question
real quick oh gosh no um something you
just said a little bit bothered me
saying something about the
CDC
um was telling pharmacies what they
could and could not you could you just
repeat that please thank you yes it was
a decision just in the last couple of
months by a federal by federal court
brought it was a suit brought by several
doctors who
were uh wanted that overturn that the
CDC could not keep telling them that
they couldn't treat people with ir
mton do you mind if some others ask you
questions oh gosh no this will be very
helpful representative weary yes thank
thank you madam chair uh could that
possibly be the FDA not the CDC it could
isn't the FDA the parent and CDC is
under it no they're they're they're
distinct organizations oh okay I I think
it's I think it's the FDA because just a
quick Google search uh talks
about F FDA and ior mechon and Court
rulings so just to clarify that on your
testimony I think I think you men this
FDA and not the CDC yes thank you very
much you're welcome what month was that
was that was this year wasn't
it um there is a um
always a trustworthy Source CNN article
on uh FDA settles lawsuit over iberin
content that doctors claimed um about
that so that was published March 27th
2024 so you're you're spot on with your
testimony um but it is the FDA and not
the CDC thank you you're welcome
represent
Penza yes I'm so I'm very familiar with
the court case and I I'm glad you
brought that up because that was my we
both kind of raised our hand at the same
time because the FDA of course is like
the controlling agency CDC just gives
out kind of the guidance and stuff so um
I just are you aware that um because I
know you said you did your own research
I did that kind of research as well that
um there were because I have a lot of
friends that have been taking icon for a
long time so before covid I was kind of
um my thing was um tickborne diseases so
um is very familiar with pharmacies that
prescribed it and um even a a major
chain so um that completely switched and
so your you know based upon your
research my research was the same and it
wasn't just mine was local of course New
Hampshire and in Maine so um that's kind
of how you the only place that I knew
that was still you know in a sense
filling those prescriptions were for
friends of mine that were had been on
ivermectin for many years because of
treatment for tickborne diseases uh
biosis lime things like that so um did
you hear did you see of any I did see a
couple compounding pharmacies um but
they were but they were a little nervous
so I'd love you to see you know there
was a compounding pharmacy in NASA that
was still filling but it was um it was
almost impossible to get it as well as
hydroxy chloroquin which um um you know
I I'll speak on after I would like you
to talk about that just your experience
and your research because I have the
same thank you very much hydroxy
chloroquin uh again was developed to
treat uh parasites and had a long
history uh of
success um and I I give great credit to
people who uh whose job whose lifetime
like Dr Corey is to to try repurpose old
medications for one thing you know
they're safe so that's a really great
place to start chances are they're
inexpensive because everybody knows how
to make them um so the the tragic thing
that happened with hydroxy chloroquin
was that in this concerted effort to
allow experimental drugs and
experimental shots to be given they had
to say there was no treatment
and so it was in financial best interest
for the people who were selling these
other
treatments was to say there was no
treatment so hydroxy
chloroquin all you had to do and I read
I tragically I I read that advisers to
president
Trump said well he said we had to do
this so we're going to make sure it
doesn't work you're going to do studies
with hydroxy chlorin on people who are
in the hospital with Co with covid it
doesn't work then it only works in the
first few days before the before the
illness has triggered the uh the the
um response to the poison in your lungs
and I just yesterday stumbled on a study
uh that was reported by Dr moin Sayad
and Dr marrick
that for the first few days for about
five days that's when you can kill the
germ the virus but then it
dies what's killing people is the
resultant poison that they've produced
in your in your body that attacks the
lining of your lungs and in fact Dr
Merrick Dr
uh Corey at first got a lot of push P
back because he said it's after first
few days you've got to you can't even
wait very long but you need to be
treating people with the anti- um
anti-inflammatories
um what is the real famous one it's
beasting yes
like prazone and all these things
similar to it you've got to treat it
doesn't do any good to a person whose
lungs are being attacked to give them an
antiviral that's not what's killing them
it's the it's their lungs and I had
heard that uh a few years ago that
people now with real serious pneumonia
and things like that are treated with
with those uh that type of medicine and
I wondered why because you know it's not
doesn't kill germs but it's because
covid victims the germs have done their
Duty and they're gone you need to kill
them right
away so um it's just every single thing
I learned pointed out that we weren't
doing it that if we listened every day
to the reports it was a body count or
count how many people were sick so it
didn't I never heard anybody recommend
that we get our immune system boosted
representative
cran um thank you so much for your
testimony today I definitely um by trade
I am an editor of scientific manuscripts
so I definitely appreciate um a lot of
the things that you're you're saying and
um agree with a lot
of that we need to do things to um I
guess boost boost our ability to do
research and do good high quality
studies and then also um improve our
ability to to actually communicate that
information out to folks so um I guess
just just digging into I think the
themes of a couple of the things that
you were saying is that um we need to be
able to to do this research faster and
then we also need to do more with with
communicating so um I guess connecting
it back to the the function of this
Committee in terms of how the state
could have responded are there things
that you think either the state of New
Hampshire could have done better
to you know be looking at at that
research and communicating that out to
to folks or um yeah how how could we
prepare next time to to be able to do
that while you know still remaining
within the the guidelines of ethical
experimentation on people well I think
just being honest and open the dialogue
so that people weren't silenced so
people weren't ridiculed when they said
oh we have an idea and this is working
well for us we should have said let's
have some forums let's have weekly
Forums on what's working
and what have you heard like all the
people I can you know I've mentioned
many many articles and I can go dig them
up so I can let you look at them and see
which ones you you think are real
impressive uh that's the most important
thing that it looks like they did a good
job and so their data is worth repeating
because that's what you want to do you
want to repeat the good stuff and see
how consistent it is that's the
scientific method um but what we need to
never do again is shut people up we
don't like what you're saying so we
we're not going to give you any coverage
we could have had
forums I'm sure we had because we would
just hear like on the grapevine from a
friend oh Dr so and so will order the
icton but look what happened to the
doctor in
Maine they took her license away and
when she was being queried maybe I'll
think of her name a little bit maybe you
can look it up but uh I actually I
actually was able to thank the uh head
guy at the U organization that provided
the money for uh legal council for her
because in Maine she was queried she
takes she tells the truth they said did
you order hydroxychloroquine for a covid
patient she said yes did you say it was
for Co she said no because they wouldn't
have filled the prescription so on that
basis they took her
license uh so
so it seems like and I don't want to put
words in your mouth and it seems like
what you were saying is that based on
your
studies that icin and hydroch chloroquin
were
prescriptions uh that were found to be
effective um against
covid but in order to get
them the doctors had to lie about what
the prescription was for in order to
treat their patients is that what you're
saying yes but I only knew of one Doctor
Who did it because the rest of them
didn't want to lose their license my own
my own
practitioner had told me in May when I
went for just an annual ual checkup I
asked her I said are you if I get Co
would you order icin she said yes in
September when I called all the
pharmacies I had found out from her she
was forbidden to order it so all I could
massive power grab by people who could
influence lots of people and so that
makes me think it's the richest people
in the country who
fund research who fund the
CDC their majority funders of the CDC
and the FDA and the NIH I always thought
those were government agencies that were
government funded but they receive like
50% of their money 30 to 50% of their
money comes from phical companies so
naturally that's going to put some
pressure on them to keep the
pharmaceutical companies happy you
wouldn't want to lose your research
money your knee deep in it you've got to
keep
going representative Belcher then
representative
cran thank you mam chair and thank you
for uh being here and providing your
testimony I'd like to drill down a
little bit on the on the issue sort of
surrounding Iber and and I'll I'll sort
of frame it the question like this um
now I don't really know whether ion
works I took it once when I had Co I
don't know if it did any good looking at
the bulk of the evidence for it you
might be some people might be surprised
to say that I I kind of lean in
direction of it probably not being
effective but I also see all of that as
kind of in a side point because the way
that we've sort of done business as far
as practicing medicine in this state and
in this country for a very long time is
the decentralization of authority
Physicians regularly and they're allowed
to prescribe medications even off label
um so if if it's not necessarily FDA
approved for a certain cause we kind of
get out of the way as the government and
say okay well Physicians are the ones
treating their patients they have the
authority to do the thing they think is
going to be effective with you know
discussing it with informed consent with
their patient to prescribe something off
label maybe it works maybe it doesn't
but I think the question is who gets to
decide that here um so would you given
your testimony would you be supportive
of of this legislature looking at ways
to protect the authority the
decentralized authority of Physicians as
opposed to sort of more of a central
planning saying that in an emergency
it's okay to sort of take that Authority
and and centralize it and say we're
going to control everything that's done
from this one location is that something
that you would you would support yes it
would have to be written extremely
carefully because I'm sure everybody
sitting here could think of dangers if
you any sentence you put in there could
end up being being harmful so yes it
would have to be but I would definitely
think that that right which is practiced
I mean off label is really common I read
a number that was like 40% you know
that's pretty high but I'll tell you
what happened the very first person that
I learned about being told
no no we'll tell you what you can do um
you'll have to look her up for me Simone
Simone gold I think it's Simone it's
last name is gold she was a physician in
California and she apparently had
already treated people who had had SARS
because we had I think it was 2010 we
had a SARS outbreak thank you yes yes
2010 and uh they found hydroxychloro con
was work for that so she was presented
with her very first case of covid and
she ordered hydroxy chloroquin and she
called them the next day and found out
they were much
better and then she got a call from her
boss who was not a medical doctor her
boss said I understand you ordered
hydroxy chloroquin she said yeah I did
he said you can't do that anymore she
said I'm the one who's
responsible for for treatment so yes I
need to order that so she didn't give
another thought until the next day when
she did it they fired her so she formed
afld DS and I'll be hardpressed to
remember all the
words American Frontline AFL D
doct yes and she has attacked it not
attacked it what's the right word she
has led it as not only are we talking
about medical freedom
but just Freedom period to have the
government intervene so seriously and
deny your rights to be treated so one of
the first laws I'd like to change is
make sure that patients have the right
to try and that doctors likewise the
doctors have the right to prescribe and
the suits will take care of that because
if somebody orders something outlandish
and it hurts people they are going to
cran thank you again thank you for
taking more of my questions um actually
I have two if that's okay um I guess my
first question is so so thinking about
the right to try like to try drugs I
definitely am in support of that um
however I do have the concern if you
know for example some popular podcaster
recommends a treatment with
you know dangerous side effects that
that's not really supported but he's got
a lot of listeners they all are very
interested to try something um you know
how do we protect people from from that
sort of situation while still
maintaining that that right to try like
who gets to make that decision of yes
you can try this versus you know no you
can't try this because it's dangerous
well my opinion is we try to educate
people that anytime anytime somebody is
recommending that you take a
medicine that you look it up and look
for the
contraindications I learned that that
was a good way to do it instead of
saying side effects put the name of the
drug and Contra indications uh because
lots lots of good drugs that people use
all the time definitely have
contraindications and people should just
get used to checking it out but that's
the person's personality cuz some people
much prefer to do it themselves and
research it and other people really want
somebody to take that off them and just
tell them you know so we can't change
people's personality but we do the best
we can to educate people that that is a
responsibility they should
assume a second question um and then I
guess just going back to to what you
were saying before about um you know the
different funding of the the nah and CDC
and all that um would you support
increasing that funding at a federal
Federal level so that do you think that
would help with bias if we were funding
more things um you know ferally versus
having to rely on private
donations yes and I think that should be
very public knowledge to how much
funding comes from Congress and how much
funding comes from people who are have a
very vested interest in their
decisions uh that reminded me of
another it slipped it'll come back
a related subject thank you well we're
on the same page as far as that
thanks represent
Penza just going back to I wanted to go
back to uh just a couple things and and
bring this all um to New Hampshire of
course because that's what we want to
you know focus on so I assume that
you're aware early on in the pandemic in
regards with what the state did um DHHS
along with the governor in restricting
their emergency order about hydroxy
chloroquin correct I can't remember when
the sequence because all I know is that
it ended up being
forbidden correct yes so that was in and
I'll I'll provide those all that
documentation for the record so just so
we have that
um because it was you know it was a
really um it was a really big deal and
it happened uh in April it was early on
in 2020 so
um and that was based upon uh saying
that they didn't just do it of course
for hydroxy chloroquin they also did it
for albuterol thinking that there was
going to you know be a shortage when
there was never a shortage that's a a
medication that is
um ridiculously in abundance so
um so I just was wondering if you
remembered that also um in regards with
uh right to try because I believe that
that is the key legislation here um I um
I had I worked with two lawsuits in New
Hampshire for folks that were um asking
for the right to try for their um loved
ones that were in the hospital and
um uh one made it and the other one died
and um and we were both um denied that
right to try so um this is a very um
intimate topic for me and hence why I
wanted to be on this committee so um
there is a family that I wanted to know
if you remember because we had a mutual
relationship with them um it was a
hospital in in Southern New Hampshire
that uh I wanted to go back to what you
talked about um specifically remember
you were talking about how hospitals
needed to get that kind of covid test
you know positive to be able to they got
expanded money and we do know that um
that there was a there was a mutual
family that was admitted to a hospital
in Southern New Hampshire they tested
for covid um negative tested again
negative third time they got that covid
positive that they needed um never
really treated him for anything he had
breathing issues but it wasn't covid and
he died in a week it was awful and that
family was denied the right to visit and
all that do you remember who we're
talking about no but I had another
because you were in the legislature at
the time and so and I remember you being
on the committee and I remember coming
to testify so
just I'm very very glad that you're on
this committee because you'll have more
to
testify excuse me than I
do
um just because you're I think all your
data is going to be very well uh you'll
have a good
bibliography now I need to go find mine
so I can give it to you um I had a
friend she was an acquaintance she was a
lovely woman who worked at the local
Post office in
Salem she was in a hospital in
Boston she got sicker and sicker she was
denied that treatment she was also
denied they they banned her family from
removing her and taking her to another
hospital again that was that killed
her I I can still see her I can see her
without even closing my eyes it still
breaks me up that this person died
needlessly but some kind of really I
just suspect that it's some kind of
really strong financial interest powered
people to make rules that were
unconscionable because they didn't want
to lose their funding or they didn't
want to lose their job all because
people had power that they shouldn't
have had so I think education open
communication is the real way to solve
any kind of problem you need to be open
and listen to everybody and if they make
sense if they make sense then people
will adopt it if they don't make sense
at least they were heard and
evaluated
followup yeah just
um all of
the re the research that you did in
regards with um off label uh hydroxy
chloroquin I have that too but I would
really appreciate if you could provide
all of that your research that you did
um history on even ior mechon um I do
know a lot about hydroxy chloroquin um
my husband took that prophylactically
and um and never had covid and it was
like a forcefield around him um when me
and my daughters had it very mildly
because we're O blood type which is
another study that never came out and uh
that I would love to talk about or
somebody to talk about but in any case
um I would um I would love I would love
you to provide all of that stuff to the
committee
um and I I I I appreciate um fellow
representative that asked you about you
know you know just some podcaster that
says hey hey this is a good treatment or
whatever that has to be clear we're not
talking about because the information
that you're talking about are drugs that
have a long history and and and used in
in other countries that were that were
really not affected by Co because and so
I would love you to provide that kind of
History um research that you've done
about hydroxy chloroquin whether it be I
Ivermectin in certain off-label drugs
that had been used repurposed um for
decades that we know a lot about so
thank you very much you just brought up
another really great is that okay if I
say you just brought up another really
wonderful fact that was never never
promoted and that is that really poor
countries where they give people
prophylactic just like in India they did
it because of covid there are people in
the poor countries in Southeast Asia and
in Africa who take uh icton on a regular
basis and it's it's not every day it's
like and and maybe it's
hydroxychloroquine too they take it
maybe well well some PE one of the
studies I read they were talking about
one of them so I'm not sure which one it
was they take it 6 months apart just a
dose maybe a couple of Doses and then 6
months later take it again those people
had hardly any covid the poorest of
people didn't have it whereas Europe and
the US with lots of lots of sick people
with lots of
money had
it representative weary yes thank you
madam chair and uh thank you I um
first just uh with regard to
hydroxychloroquine I've traveled to
India a lot and so I've had to take it
prophylactically um and um and have
watched uh a number of colleagues take
it prophylactically and and I think the
only problems that one individual I had
that I knew had with it was that he had
been going for an extended period and so
had some blurred vision issues which is
one of the side effects commonly listed
for hydroxy chloroquin and and so it it
alarmed me when I started seeing reports
that um that were being put in the news
that this caused heart attacks and um so
it it brought up which my colleague had
mentioned before the risk benefit ratio
I think is is part of this Trifecta or
trifold thing is we we want to balance a
patient's right to try we want to
balance Health Care practitioners off
label use and the right to practice
medicine as they've been trained to do
and then we also want to carefully
balance that risk benefit ratio where
you have I think a hydroxy chloroquin
and Ivermectin ostensibly have extremely
low risk to the people consuming it and
potentially given the nature of Co a
high benefit and so to
suppress something that has that kind of
ratio of of risk benefit seems to me to
be
um well not only tragic but but um uh
borderline criminal if not criminal um
so I think in trying to govern or
or kind of find where we want to make
some recommendations I think you've
helped us really find that that sort of
Sweet Spot between those three factors
um in your testimony today I think it's
been very
and
um as a chemist you're probably a little
better educated on some of these matters
than the typical consumer any advice for
how you would
communicate besides having them read
contra indications off a patient you
know package insert or something like
that how would you try to better
communicate the risk benefit ratio to
the average
consumer
forums I all I can think is that people
who are interested in the subject uh
should volunteer and we should support
public
forums because then if we gave some
acknowledgement that that's important
the news media might ignore the fact
that a lot of them are dependent on ads
by pharmaceutical companies I
mean I feel like I'm being crass to say
this but I really feel money had a lot
to do with the decisions and the
policies that were made because we had
news media that really if you if you
count the ads that you see on on TV lots
of them are medicines Lots so the their
income if you make them mad by saying
something critical or saying you know
well it's going to be critical if you
say if you counter contradict what
they're saying because that was pretty
bad that you had to go to court and
finally in
2024 get a a legal decision that a
government agency can no longer tell you
what medicines you can you can take uh
that was a lot of people who were
strangled by by the financial power of
pharmaceutical companies and I'm
dependent on pharmaceutical companies
you know I take lyro and every day
aren't I lucky to live in a country
where that's really cheap and available
um represen gr thank
you first of all please accept my
condolences for the loss of your
friend and I'd like to um focus a little
bit on the idea of a forum because I
think that brings it back to New
Hampshire can you um share with me your
thoughts on that and
how
um what is your vision for that forum
and how do you think it would
um uh
benefit the state and the and gr
inators well good health for our people
definitely benefits all of
us I haven't thought about how to put
forums together but all I knew was that
it was so strong in my thoughts these
people that we need to hear from are
being silenced they're not being given a
microphone so uh I'm sure other people
can help think of it can't just be top
brass talking I really valued the
opinions of people who were taking care
of patients the ICU doctors who were
being ridiculed whose patients were
living and surviving to me they were the
ones we should be listening to not some
guy in an ivory Tower making what
$500,000 a year uh on his
patents huh
I want to hear from from everybody if if
the people in the Ivory Towers are
saying wrong things then the people who
are actually treating patients are going
to refute that but they have to be
protected right at the way it was they
had already been threatened with losing
their Li their their license if they
ordered those two medications so How
likely were they to say it
publicly I have a follow-up question so
aside from the Ivor mechon discussion I
mean this is just a I'm just talking
about how do you or how do we as a state
use what's happened in the past so that
if something happens in the future where
we have some robustness to our
process so don't forget the people in
the Ivory Tower forget all the money
forget all I'm talking about the basic
Grassroots
forum and how you how that could happen
and how that could fit into the whole
Response well of course I wish the
emergency response had been encouraging
people to increase their
immunity
because most Americans whether they live
where there's lots of sun or not are low
in D the people who live I just went
back and visited my family and friends
in the in Texas they have lots of
sunshine they also because of it have
lots of air conditioning so that doesn't
mean they're out in the
sun yeah uh people need to know what
their level is if they're low
um you know it's really shocking to me
it was a pleasant shock but it's still
surprising that vitamins still are
profoundly now being connected our our
lack of vitamins are being pro uh
connected to serious illness and that's
a shock because I just guess I grew up
thinking that you needed some really
sophisticated medications to treat never
even thought about
prevention um and gradually from
learning from other people I take lots
of vitamins um and uh you you know I'm
lucky enough to be able to afford it cuz
it's really it really is expensive if
you take as many as I do um but most
people could afford D it's really cheap
most people could afford C uh I just
think education and open communication
so we could pass laws to make sure they
don't get shut down again that's the
major thing that I'm thinking of right
now thank you very much
and thank you Betty and I love the idea
of a form but I'm going to play devil's
advocate here okay um if we did create a
forum knowing what we know and doctors
and being afraid to lose their
license How likely would they be to
share in a forum not
likely um my other qu thing is is the
importance of V vins on our immune
system and helping to fight off diseases
and viruses and obviously vitamin D
extremely important I know that my
family my boys are now uh they're taking
it in a liquid form um so it goes
directly into their bloodstream because
they found that they were low in vitamin
D um but I don't know if there is such a
thing but having a pamphlet or something
on the website of
HHS uh telling you
know talking about vitamins and how
important they are and what they
actually combat so people can understand
that you know vitamin D yeah you can get
it from the Sun but you don't
necessarily you might not be someone who
absorbs it um and you know if you have
enough vitamin C it can help combat
these different ailments so the showing
them what the benefits are of doing
something like this um would make people
more apt to pay attention
as opposed to not uh I'm ju Just a
thought on that what are your thoughts
oh I think that's a great idea because
you're never going to have to worry that
you're putting down that you're let's
see extolling the answer the this is it
which is really my criticism of what we
were given when we were going through Co
we know everything this is what you have
to do this is only thing that'll work
we're not really interested in what you
have to say so but you can give people
all kind of information and encourage
them to do their own studying so that
you're not saying oh here's what we
recommend this many milligrams of C this
many milligrams of e this many
milligrams of of D if you recommend it
and then always say you encourage people
to do their own their own research and
see what works well for them I think you
protect your yourself and you're
honest never just saying this is it that
I guess that was another thing that just
hit me and I never had the words for it
I'm getting told exactly what I have to
do even though I can't discuss it I'm
ridiculed if I disagree with it the very
idea of shutting down all kind of
businesses and then choosing a few that
could stay away stay and then giving
some money hoping to make up for the
money they lost that should have been
People's Choice to go yeah what stores
to go to where they felt
safe right and and you know I totally
agree with you and just want to go back
to something that we need to also uh
educate people that they need to be
responsible
take responsibility for their health I
had just contacted a doctor about
something and she's like well you know I
think you know maybe a dose of steroids
and I'm like yeah no we're not going to
try that right now um but it was a open
communication we were able to discuss
it I know what the side effects are
and it wasn't essential so it was a good
back and forth and it was ultimately my
decision and I think being able to be a
decision maker in our health care which
seems to be one of the things that
didn't happen during covid um we were
told what had to happen and what
couldn't happen
and being respons ible adults um and
knowing our bodies because everybody's
body is different reacts differently um
people some people are more aware what's
going on with them other people aren't
but I think that there has to be a give
and take and a one- siiz fits-all is in
my opinion is never the solution to
anything um because of diversity um do
you what are your thoughts on that of
course I that's my philosophy too and
you know we like to think we like to
think that uh people can you can make
people do things a doctor can order
whatever they
want the patient may never take it so
ultimately patients always have the
choice of not following it's just they
don't have the choice of getting
medications that they think they need if
they can't find a p practitioner willing
to order it
represent
Penza so would you believe that when
patients were in the hospital being
treated
for covid that when um loved ones asked
for infusions of vitamin d and vitamin C
and other supplements that they were
denied are you familiar with that yes I
I was amazed to find out how amazingly
infusions of vitamin C have saved people
from um what's the illness where your
your blood
system what is the word anyway it's it's
can easily be fatal and your blood
system is just infected and it's just
just amazing and so if you have a a
doctor who's willing who's never done it
but is willing to go and see what other
what other doctors have used for dosages
you know to me that's that's a good
doctor yeah so that that that right
there those um denials of of basic
things that we've known same thing
forever right were um maddening that it
was really difficult I do want to go
back to the supplement piece because I
think that is so important and you know
I think that we have to if we're going
to really focus on health and Immunity
and all of those things I know and
there's probably other people here that
have children as well um that when I've
brought my kids to the
pediatrician they always ask what
they're taking in regards with they want
to make sure that they're taking
vitamins especially d and c and a multi
and all of that because there's no
possible way that you can get enough
from intake of food during the day and
um and in regards with public forums
that's the other piece that's so
important too because there's a lot of
them like I've heard you know we've had
you know Health Freedom New Hampshire is
one of them there's a rise up New
Hampshire group that's uh further out in
they're like in the Keen area um that
have done forums about this stuff as
well um many many natural doctors um but
many traditional doctors too especially
that ones that are treating with
children I've noticed that um they've
always been on that path so it would be
really nice to have the upper echelon
you know whether that is like you know a
DHHS or whatever that is truly promoting
that as well so I just you know there
has been forums it's just not in that
mainstream and I think that's what we
all kind of are talking about here how
can we make that be mainstream right I
mean because this information is out
there and we we kind of gravitate toward
circles that are given it but um there's
been a recent study uh in a sense in the
last year that came out um it was huge
it talked about niin in vitamin B being
a huge Fighter for covid um in addition
to stuff that we already knew from
vitamin D and it was just so sad that
that's not mainstream right so we we
just need to make more more educational
opportunities and make it but giving our
blessing as a governmental agency I
think does boost the the approval and uh
acceptance that it's an important
subject so I think we have the
information but most of us haven't heard
it if we didn't have much time to dig in
covid times we had more time than we
knew what to do with uh because we were
so prevented from doing other things but
mostly in a busy life you really need to
know that somebody
has given their stamp of approval this
is a good website to look at are on the
news they actually cover uh cover people
who are making great strides are have
noted that people are healthier you know
anyway positive positive information
do do you have anything else you'd like
to add no I just really appreciate that
y'all are so interested and that you
volunteered for this really really
really important committee um I think
it's
absolutely we're not blue or red on this
subject I think we all really care to
imp improve the health of our neighbors
and to make sure that our our
laws really support really support
people finding out what they can do to
help their health and uh nutrition is
really big and uh a lot of people get
scared when you say nutrition it's like
now I'm going to have to give up all the
things I really like to
eat so anyway thank you so much I really
appreciate it because I've really felt
bad coming in not prepared with anything
in good sequential order and know I was
dying to come well thank you for
testifying and if you could email the
committee your your documentation that
would be wonderful that way we go luck
thank you take your time we we have time
okay thank you very much you're welcome
weekend uh I have no other pin cards but
is there anybody else in the audience
that would like to speak representative
good morning to all of you and everyone
watching um thank you all sincerely for
serving on this committee I know that
it's been um a lot of time on a
beautiful Friday especially and uh it's
so important that you hear from the
public um about the pandemic um my name
is representative Emily Phillips from
Fremont New Hampshire that's Rockingham
district 7 I am a Freshman rap I uh was
serving on a school board during the
pandemic and uh that was a trip so uh
yeah it kind of motivated me to run for
office I um I know that this you you
have a charge and you want to come up
with uh the truth in what happened at
the state and produce that for the
public and I appreciate that but maybe
hopefully we come up with legislation
that's meaningful uh to improve the
state's response should this happen
again right so I am not a scientist I am
just a mother I sell packaging and I'm a
State Rep so I don't have expertise on
what was done correctly or incorrectly I
just have um uh stories from the public
and what I've learned in other hearings
um I have some concerns about how the
state uh the DHHS agency is still
promoting the covid vaccine for children
I don't believe there's evidence to
support that I would like this committee
to um maybe work on a directive so we
stop that until this evidence to support
um promoting uh covid vaccines for
children I have heard in other testimony
for various bills that uh at least three
but maybe five children have died um and
it's been linked to the vaccine or or
one of the vaccines that was used for
covid um under emergency youth
authorization one death is too many um
we should not be promoting this and
wasting our taxpayer funds promoting the
covid vaccines for
children I would like to see health and
health benefits promoted by the state I
don't see any campaigns uh to promote
you know a healthy diet physical
exercise vitamin D vitamin D is so
important um I don't see any advertising
for that and I believe what the former
representative uh representative bet gay
had said that it's all linked to money
and advertisements um DHHS is in the
business of vaccines they make money
from this
that is not disputed so we need to see
the state promoting good health
standards immune systems work um there
are so many people who were told to stop
exercising to stay indoors um all these
Preposterous ideas that we um were
following and it wasn't promoting good
health I would like to see the committee
get DHHS on track to improve Public
Health I do believe that health is
individual I think everyone is unique
and we should allow providers to
um prescribe whatever they seem you know
deem fit for their um patient uh I
support everything that was just said um
I would just like to see we're using
public funds let's promote public health
and real health programs right like not
just whatever is prescribed by the Ivory
Tower um I was watching since we're just
is kind of like an open we can just kind
of testify okay so um I was following uh
Children's Health defense and I listened
to the testimony of a woman um whose son
ended up getting um he was in seventh
grade and he showed up for a physical
and he got a basic blood work done or um
it was like a blood work analysis and a
UR analysis and then he got his vaccine
of choice and I think it was like a Tdap
or something so he got that um he got
the vaccine on for the child just
schedule right after that um test and so
he ended up having a reaction he got um
type 1 diabetes um 30 days later now she
the mother believes that that's
correlated to that tab vaccine so she
happened to have gotten that analysis
her blood work done um that day so they
could see your marker for the autoimmune
reaction and they were able to link it
to that particular vaccine I thought it
was interesting because she had passed a
bill in her home state I don't have that
information I'll find it for you but the
child's name was
Braden uh bonan and I'm going to get
that information um but basically they
were asking Physicians to to offer to
their patients a baseline blood work or
urine analysis at the time of
vaccination and I thought that was
interesting because it's an option like
just to offer it to the parent before
you get vaccinated do you want this you
have some sort of Baseline because as we
know um there's no ability to prove a
vaccine injury I mean really um we have
a hard enough time getting people to
report to Bears um so this gives a uh a
parent or a patient the opportunity to
just get like a health check and it's
only going to improve people's ability
to catch early signs of say cancer or
any kind of elevated issues in your
blood work uh as adults we are offered
Baseline blood work um at least annually
I think maybe it's every other year um
but it's just part of our good Wellness
checks right we get like a baseline they
can catch high levels of you know I'm
not a scientist but you know whatever it
might be alarming in your blood work so
and it's a relatively cheap uh
Laboratory test to run so I like the
idea of that um is to maybe have a
legislation encouraging Physicians to
offer that to children because children
don't get blood work baselines usually
right are not offered it so something
like that um another idea for
legislation I thought is that maybe we
um encourage our physicians in the state
to uh report vaccine injuries to the VS
System I just looked it up on CDC and
for covid uh they're not required to
unless they're under emergency youth
authorization and it's a severe reaction
and they are only encouraged to for the
licensed um shots like the bio in tech
one and and comity or whatever they are
um encouraged to uh for any other
reaction but we know that they're under
reported that's been testified here
before so it's hard
to you know measure things when we don't
have accurate data so um you know other
I'm open to questions but I'm just kind
of rambling unprepared so thank you
representative um quick question for you
um I find it interesting that the mom
had the blood test in the urine analysis
um I think that's a great idea
um do you so for legislation because I'm
not one for mandates um but do you think
it should be mandated to
physicians in New Hampshire
that they must
offer to
the person the patient the option not
mandate that it be done but mandate that
they give the
option um and that way it's up to the
patient uh their
choice um but also with the Mandate I
guess having a reason why they would be
doing that uh whether it be for a marker
or just to have a baseline so that it uh
because to me um I never even thought
about until you just brought it up uh so
you could kind of chart your health and
what's going on in your body or your
children's body um so I think it could
be an option
um so what are your thoughts on that you
said it better than I did like I said I
was trying to watch the um the Twitter
feed where I learned about this to find
out more information and I will get that
to you guys but the option sorry the I'm
all against mandates as well but just to
have a physician and maybe this is
compelled speech so people might be
freaking out but just to have a doctor
offer it to a parent now if you have
insurance or Medicaid or whatever like
these tests are relatively inexpensive
and and a person may say no thank you
because a lot of people don't want to
have their child you know get blood
drawn that's pretty traumatic but the
option is there and it does allow a more
accurate snapshot of your child's health
to have even a routine urine analysis
that's no big deal too um but having any
kind of Baseline just so you can say
something changed right and I'm and this
relates to the covid vaccine or any
vaccine and maybe this is not out of the
parameter of of legislation you would
consider but I thought it was very
interesting as a backstory I do also
have type 1 diabetes so I know the
autoimmune component um to it so I
thought it was interested I don't know
exactly what caus mine but who knows
know um and I certainly didn't have
blood work uh before my routine
childhood vaccines as well so um I like
the idea of it and offering people more
options informed consent to their
healthare is something I think that
everyone should be on board with so
thank you for clarifying representative
beler uh thank you for coming and thank
you for testifying um you know I I know
a little bit about your story and I
would love
you know today was kind of put aside for
the public for um for us to be able you
know for everybody to be able to share
kind of maybe personal experience how um
the pandemic affected them or whatever
and giving examples of that and you have
a lot of that um in regards with your
time like you said um on the school
board but more of that just you know in
the community but with your own family
and and so of course I've seen your
testimony on other things with
legislation um you know I know why you
ran it's kind of the same reason why I
ran um as a new rep
so you know you've got an open Forum to
really speak about that here and I think
it's um it's really valid about what you
experienced whether it be at school and
stuff like that and I'd love to hear it
so um now I think I know what you're
saying so uh during covid uh my school
actually opened up full force in
September of 2021 we all closed down in
March and my school is in Fremont New
Hampshire Ellis school it's a k through
K through 8 uh school and we decided on
the Schoolboard that we're going to open
and we're not going to do this hybrid
learning you know every other day half
the body we're not going to do remote
we're going to open and um we had an
online option for parents who were not
comfortable to have their children
returned in person so I think about 25%
of our student body of 400 and change
did an online option for that whole year
and then the other you know 300 kids
came to school in um September of 2021
we had a policy for or um as you recall
the the governor didn't set a policy for
any kind of masks or mandates they said
each School District make up your own
policy so we did a we passed a policy
requiring face coverings face coverings
included um masks uh hospital grade or
cloth or a plastic face shield whatever
so uh choose your path and about eight
students in my population um chose to
wore plastic face shields uh two of my
children at the time only had two uh
they have uh individual education plans
they're special ed and both for speech
and language so I chose the plastic face
Shields and um they were in second grade
in kindergarten or first grade in
kindergarten at the time um no problems
were really had until kids started
treating my old oldest differently they
wouldn't want um one situation is my
child was put with another child to work
on a project and that child said I don't
want to work with Colin because he
doesn't wear a face mask uh and so the
teacher in the moment said okay Colin
I'm going to assign you to some other
student is that okay instead of using
that opportunity to say you're both safe
and um you're going to work together and
everyone here is fine and healthy and
you're going to work together there's
nothing different about Colin no so it's
just like when we do things like this we
kind of make like invisible disabilities
very visible because Colin couldn't wear
a face mask cuz he no one could
understand him my daughter um was mute
uh she was a very late speaker we had
tons of ear infections and all sorts of
stuff so she was she started preschool
during covid uh went to kindergarten in
2021 and all of her peers were wearing
masks she was supposed to get uh speech
and language therapy every day um during
covid a lot of these special education
services went out the window because we
had special education providers just
holding down the Ford right we had them
we didn't do sub stitutes in our school
because we were concerned about the
virus coming in so we had every time a
teacher had to be out because they had
their own child care issues or whatever
we had a special education teacher
subbing in that room so basically let's
be honest here children took the brunt
of covid okay so my children didn't get
their special ed services and no other
children in this entire State got what
they were entitled to during Co um so my
daughter was not speaking in
kindergarten um because
she couldn't read lips so that's how she
was um overcoming the fact that so when
everyone covered their face she didn't
understand what was going on and even
when people speak to me in math
sometimes I think that I'm a li lip
reader as well so she would just be
quiet she would go along to get along
follow the path um I ended up holding
her back in kindergarten um because I
wanted her to actually have that play
based year but we're talking about um
Square bears in tape drawn on the floor
and the kindergarteners would sit they
didn't have tables because they didn't
want kids using communal spaces so they
had the kids sit in little squares in
kindergarten so I called it preschool
prison because that's what it looked
like they drew a you know they showed us
all these squares these kids were going
to sit inan style on and learn and there
was going to be no interaction no
touching it you know and I was sending
her there so she could get her Services
um after that year they said she's still
not talking I said she doesn't know
anyone's
names um so she's now a year past
kindergarten but she's still in
kindergarten and special ed was like
yeah we
um she doesn't speak at school and I
said she's scared I said she goes to
summer camp and she you know she she
talks and and by the way summer camp
didn't require anyone to wear masks so
it's like we're we're all just playing
our own game here and um the school
basically hinted that she had some sort
of psychological situation going on so
they suspected now they do not diagnose
in public school okay but they were
hinting around that she had selective
mutism selective mutism is an anxiety
based disorder where you you know you
just get all overwhelmed and you don't
speak and the only solution the only
approved uh treatment for Selective
mutism is anxiety medication for my
six-year-old and if we don't treat it
then she's going to clam up and then
eventually she'll you know
self self-medicate um you know with who
knows you know cutting or you know drugs
or whatever that's what they say they
say if she doesn't get overcome this
anxiety by eight she's doomed so I said
okay I'm going to homeschool I
homeschooled this is in 2022 and I ended
up running for office it was just a
whole hot mess but my daughter is fine
she's good she's she's talking she's now
back in a charter school um and I and
she's having a great time and it was
really just her peers being covered that
she couldn't form those connections so
my daughter is probably one of thousands
you know if not millions of children who
just panicked and like could I have
chosen to medicate her could I have
chosen to start
therapy and and do all these other
things yes but I I just said we need a
mental health year so we took them out
and we did some co-ops for a year and um
I ended up retaining my son who's now in
fourth grade should be in fifth grade
and put them in a public charter school
this year and they're doing great and
everything's back to normal right so
that I think that's why people are like
why are we even doing this this
committee it's like everything's fine
you know the chains are looser but
they're still chains you know like like
we we need to make sure that this
doesn't happen again because we
sacrificed an entire generation for this
and everyone's trying to act like let's
move on okay all the kids are behind
it's not okay and we're moving the
milestones and we're we're saying it's
all right you know we didn't know or we
you know everyone was doing their best
well like this is what this is for right
now right here to make sure that we
don't do this again
um my uh my daughter like I said was
very very quiet and she was at summer
camp and um I took her for a wellness
visit this is during 2021 and I show up
with the Wellness visit and um we're
taking off her shoes and her ankle's
black and I'm like what happened to your
ankle she like oh I I heard it on the
trampoline and I was like did you tell
anyone and she's like no you know cuz
she's quiet and she's scared cuz
everyone's wearing masks around her like
they didn't require her to wear anything
but like they were still counselors and
everything she just was shy and scared
but it's like she had like cracked her
ankle like it basically was a s brain
but like I was horrified cuz I'm like at
the doctor I'm like I didn't know she
had hurt her ankles like black and like
okay she's fine we had a x-ray and she
was fine but the SE kids are like scared
to challenge adults or tell people
things especially with the mask on masks
are scary to little kids imagine the
kids down in daycare like we've seen the
videos of people putting masks on
2-year-old kids like have you anyone
ever had a
2-year-old like it's just absurd I I now
have an almost three-year-old but um I
just think it's so funny that they think
intellectually that when you turn two
you're able to wear a face mask like who
decided that you know and then there's
daycares who won't let you come in if
your kid can't wear a mask all day it's
like I can't wear a mask all day so um I
don't know what else is relevant to my
story but um I just
I I think that we need to think about
all the people who are silent and who
don't have a voice like we're all here
and we all have a backbone and we're
here and we're speaking for what we
believe is right but like there are so
many people who are scared to come out
and challenge things and say that's not
that's not fair that wasn't right and
like or they're gone and they're
dead I mean whether be Hospital
protocols or a vaccine injury or they
took their own life like how much mental
illness has has come from this the
shutting down people lost their
businesses they lost their careers they
lost family members suddenly and
unexpectedly I am 40 I turned 40 this
year I don't have never ever seen so
many people in their 30 and 40s dying in
their
sleep I am not a scientist I can't say
definitively what it is but something is
up and I'm not saying this is a state
issue I I'm just um I just I I would
just like to see DHHS support Public
Health if that's truly what they're in
it for there are so many ways to improve
people's immune response to everything
uh and the health overall that is just
not being done we don't we don't spend
money on actual Health campaigns here
and if I'm giving my tax money I'd like
to see people talk about
exercise talk about vaccine like um how
to report um
what you suspect to be a vaccine you
know injury because if it's true we need
to have the data right
[Music]
um I don't know I think a lot of people
have changed course um I um vaccinated
my first two children I'm in a I was in
a vaccine study up until three years ago
I have all these scars in my back from a
vaccine that I had taken five different
shots to try to help with type 1
diabetes I Am pro science I've donated
myself and my time to so many um
different um uh studies for medical
devices and vaccines like I said I'm
Type 1 diabetic I just I'm
hesitant like I don't trust what's being
said on the news because of who's paying
for the
advertisement like why would they ever
post anything or do a Evening News
critical of a pharmaceutical product
when their number one
donor is Big Pharma so I'm I'm just one
I'm saying it out loud a lot of people
won't say it but I I mean it like there
are people like me who have changed
course and are hesitant of what has been
tried and true recommended Healthcare
and it's like I'm not the only one so
how do we make people more confident in
the state of New Hampshire because I
think like we can't change the impact of
people's opinions on the CDC or the FDA
I don't think we can influence that but
how do we make people trust the New
Hampshire government and how they will
respond in the next
situation um represent uh if you don't
mind
um do you think that if we had
um people from the scientific
Community discussing in a
forum uh type instead of just one person
re basically
reiterating what was coming down from
the CDC or the the
FDA that um New Hampshire would take
responsibility for what it is putting
out
um and doing our own research here to
protect our citizens do you think that
might be something that we should look
into yes um I think I wasn't a sitting
State Rep during the pandemic most of
you were so did you get emails from your
constituents like save us help us help
my business stop this I'm going to lose
my job help me and did you feel
powerless like I think we tried to limit
executive powers uh this term um I think
people want want more representation
instead of it being regurgitated from
whoever is calling the shots at the
federal level and then we're being told
that it's oh it's local control but is
it though because like as a Schoolboard
member we wanted directives from the
governor we wanted the governor to tell
us how to set our policies and and and
because we were getting the hate mail at
the local level right and so like I said
I was I was fortunate that we had a lot
more Liberty at my local school district
and we did not have any outbreaks there
was nothing nothing terrible happened in
my school system at all besides you know
like I said some maybe some bullying or
whatever but we function very well and
our kids are better for it and our in
our and our school district is better
for it um now there are other school
districts you know that went um either
fully remote or they did this hybrid
thing where kids were coming Tuesday
Thursdays Monday Wednesdays trying to
divide and we're just trying to panic
and survive meanwhile the teachers kids
weren't in school and they couldn't come
to work and it was just a it was just an
absolute mess so um I think that having
more decision makers more qualified
people and not just one person
regurgitating the same story it is what
the people want that's what this this
legislative body is all about let me ask
another qu the question another way
sorry no no you answered perfectly but
I'm just going to uh pivot a little bit
if the
government of New Hampshire is receiving
funding from the federal government are
we not beholden to do what they say and
how would we overcome
that all federal funding has strings
attached
um we got to read the fine print um how
do we overcome that we could just not
take the
money we are we are a surplus
State
um if we are concerned with the strings
I don't so I'm being told that some of
the fine lines and all of the federal
funding you know oh that's not real or
they would never do that but I I mean I
read things literally for what they say
so I have
concerns well I can tell you and I'm
going to go off topic a little bit that
we have a very obscure law on the books
from
1986 uh how do I know this because this
is uh what happened to my son is that in
order to accept federal
funds we put a law on the books that
says that if you are in a six-wheel dump
belt and my son got a ticket for that
with Farm plates on the truck
so uh anyways I believe representative
belshire had a
question thank you madam chair thank you
for your testimony I just wanted to ask
if you were aware of um the fact that
roughly within the last week uh Dr
Deborah Burks who was really fundamental
in at the federal level in the pandemic
uh did an interview with Chris Cuomo in
which she called for an uh investigation
into vaccine injury acknowledging that
there are at least thousands of vaccine
injured
patients I wasn't aware of it but I'm
not surprised
representative
Penza so just going back to a couple of
the things that you said and I you know
following some of the legislation that
you had put
forward you know um what we could do as
as legislators because you know in a
sense um we're here from our
constituents they're the boss and um and
we should be you know the the whole
reason why I'm here is uh because I
believe that we need to protect their
rights
so what about in regards with like of
course it needs to come from our health
agency that that it has to come there
but what could we do whether it be with
legislation with informed consent I
think that's first and foremost more
than anything else um in and giving
people that kind of besides giving them
inform forms consent and and showing
them what their you know in a sense
their options are like how do you
formulate that um that we could get that
coming not just what we do through law
but making that a reality for New
Hampshire
families I did sponsor a bill um that
did not pass the house it was HB 575 uh
last year and then it became another
spin-off uh SB 319 which was informed
consent when it comes to the state
purchasing promoting and distributing uh
vaccines or pharmaceutical products that
have not completed clinical human
trials um most people think that makes
perfect sense now that wouldn't that
would still allow private uh providers
or hospitals to purchase and promote and
and sell whatever vaccine anybody wants
right um unfortunately neither bill
passed I believe it was interim studied
in the Senate most recently so we just
have a lot of people
um I don't know if the data is is is
sufficient enough for some people or if
they're if their heads in the sand or
they or who knows but they're they're
not seeing that this is actually testing
unproven products on our population uh
and now the state is paying for it with
taxpayer dollars so um yeah I'm I'm big
on con informed consent so I I would
like to see all sorts of legislation um
make sure that the conversation between
a provider and a patient is thorough and
that they know what they're um
consenting to because I think all too
often it's minimal or it's not happening
at all um and people don't really know
no represent
leus do you know how many W or which
vaccines have actually been had full
clinical trials and approval and
everything I believe the answer is um if
you're referring to the childhood
vaccine schedule
none
um so
after the roll out that's when it's
happening so what's happening now is the
clinical human trials for the for the
covid vaccine um so I
um I mean maybe you know the answer to
your own question but I believe the
answer like I don't I so even like the
flu vaccine is new every year so that
was one of the OB obstacles or um
objections to my original bill was that
this would not allow us to promote and
sell the flu vaccine because it changes
it slightly is altered every year based
on what they predict will be the strain
or dominant few strains um so I guess I
just don't know the answer to that
question but I don't believe that many
pharmaceutical products do not do
clinical testing real true blinded
double blinded it's it's it's a study
usually funded by the manufacturer
themselves and it's very small so
um again I don't I don't work for them
but I don't think I don't think a lot of
stuff that comes to Market is fully
clinically human trial like that we wish
it would be
just a piggy back off of uh what
represent leus just said I never really
considered the flu shot as I always
called it a vaccine because I thought
vaccine was a little bit different it
was the flu comes back every year uh so
that that it's a shot that you have to
get every year where a vaccine is to
help stop the spread of disease measles
moms polio Etc um am I missing
something I agree I mean even the co
shot is not a vaccine um because we all
know now that uh initially we were told
it would stop but it it doesn't stop
transmission right it's alleged to um
minimize severe illness and decrease
hospitalization that's the latest I've
been told about it um yeah I agree with
you uh regarding the covid
shot or vaccine however you want to
whatever terminology you want to use um
do you think that when it was rolled out
it was labeled safe and effective do you
think that was truth in
labeling no how could it
tested does anyone else have any
so I'm not sure when this was it was
several months ago when um I'm not sure
if there's some people on this committee
but in regards with there was a um I
know some people that are on HHS would
know um Gary would probably
representative Merchant would probably
know but in any case there was a a form
or a a notice that was on
DHHS that they said wasn't there but it
was found and and it's been subsequently
saved and you can't find it now but that
was still promoting um CU it's kind of
like what you said in your first of your
testimony the childhood um experimental
gene therapy which is what I call it
let's call it what it is in regards with
those injections for children with covid
and um so that that sheet that promotion
sheet is now no longer on DHHS but um
and they said they weren't promoting it
but they were and so um are you familiar
with that whole whole thing that
happened it was several months ago and
it was a little bit of a yeah so it was
a graphic for the childhood vaccine
schedule which is normal on what is
required for entry to childcare or
daycare but at the bottom of it it was
recommended the covid-19 shot so like
what I'm saying is that we shouldn't be
even recommending
it there's no science to recommend it so
it's not required as part of so a low
information person would go to to to
that page and say what does my kid need
they're seven what do they need okay uh
yep Co everything so it was listed
within within the graph of Ages like on
on in the annual flu and the annual
covid now the flu is not required either
to go to school but it's in there so I'm
just saying when you print out that
graphic or it's put put on the wall at
your local pediatricians you're leading
people to believe now these are like
little words that you know legislators
catch or whatever but the average person
are going to say oh this is recommended
I got to get this um so yeah I don't I
don't believe it's there anymore it was
changed when it was pointed out but um
now DHHS will testify that we will never
mandate the covid shot
um but that those are just words so
they're recommending it on sheets that's
what that's what I I guess by now I
think the majority of the room the
majority of the state understand that
this virus was never really a thread to
children and that the myocarditis risk
for especially young boys is enough to
say let's stop promoting it you can
choose it for your child you can choose
it for yourself but why are we pushing
it with State funds with taxpayer
dollars it's just not there protect the
people who might benefit from this if
that population exists it's not the
children do you believe that should be
between the doctor and the patient yes
thank you represent poens a followup
yeah I think what you just said um it
just kind of hits the nail on the head
for me this was about um a month and a
half ago I was at the gas station and
I'm sure we're all familiar with the gas
stations that have um most of them do
now they're newer and they have the uh I
don't know it's kind of like a little
screen and it tries to sell you on
something while you're filling your tank
well there was uh an ad specifically in
regards with covid injections from DHHS
that was on the gas what is going on why
are we spending the money on that versus
spending the money on education and
health and all of that and this is where
I I really believe there where there is
risk there needs to be choice and where
there needs to be informed consent and
where DHHS my gosh how great would it be
if at these you know gas stations there
promoting health and and in nutrition
and and supplements and all of that kind
of stuff versus
an injection so yeah I mean what if they
were promoting getting your child a
basic blood work
panel you know I I just um I I
completely agree with what you just said
so I I just
um we're just using taxpayer so I said
it before and I'll say it again for
people who need the clip but DHHS is in
the vaccine business so that is why they
are promoting it they make money off of
this okay it might be federal funds and
it's all our tax payer dollars but it
you know what I'm saying like they are
making money off of this so they are
going to promote it and the end so this
is a product that they can continue to
sell so that is why it's on every corner
at Walgreens and it's you know being
promoted because they have to spend the
money because guess what if DHHS doesn't
spend their money their budget might be
affected next year right if they stop
spending money then they're going to
we're going to say oh you used less than
we you were budgeted let's let's trim
that down maybe you know the people in
finance in the budget year next year
might say oh we don't need all this
money so they're going to continue to
spend this when a lot of people are not
buying what they're selling anymore
whether they bought it initially people
are fatigued or they've changed their
mind but they are these products are not
being consumed like they were two years
ago so um they're just going to continue
to promote it because they're just
trying to sell the product
representative weary yes thank you mam
chair and thank you representative
Phillips for taking my question I'd like
to touch upon a tangent gential aspect
to this that I that I I think
you've the discussion about diabetes has
reminded me
that fatalities associated with covid
were often patients who had a multitude
of
comorbidities so there was in some cases
you know diabetes obesity other
illnesses and it was really uh extreme
high percentage of those patients or
those people who died um from covid
because they had uh a number of other
mitigating health conditions and and not
and it was surprising because I remember
seeing the statistics at one
point it was a multiplicity of
conditions not a singular condition so
diabetes wasn't a death sentence with
covid it was merely
you know something to be precautious
about but if you had a multitude of
these on top of each other of these
comorbidities then you really had a much
greater chance
of not only you know catching covid but
but be probably because of a weakened
immune system of really then succumbing
to
covid and
what I I think this ties into to the
discussion that that you've introduced
to us about the advertising because I
think if
you're telling people that it's that
this is a deadly disease but not
revealing that it's deadly to people who
have low immunity and
comorbidities then you're creating this
illusion
that that this disease is deadly to all
and I think think you know we really
didn't see that we we certainly don't
see that for
children um so I'm wondering I'd like
your opinion
does not having enough information about
the and the fear aspect of that would
incentivize the as you termed it the
lowi informed person who is who is not
really doing their own research
what would incentivize them do you how
how big a factor could this fear in not
having all this information incentivize
them to to
need that was a lot um so no so I agree
with you that it that it the way it's
marketed is that this is a dangerous
virus for all and and also it markets
the the shot that this will be
beneficial to all and everyone should
get it and a lot of the times it's do it
to help out others that was the
messaging early on is that I'm doing it
for my community I'm going to take this
shot to help slow the spread or you know
um but now we know that you don't um
have a less of a chance of catching it
in fact you may just be lower symptoms
and you may be going out and about when
you are sick and you're just your viral
load is lower right or your symptoms are
masked and then you're passing it on to
a newborn baby or your your elderly
parent in the nursing home so um I guess
yeah I just feel like if there's going
to be a campaign of of taxpayer money
now I can't stop fizer and Monna from
being being who they are and marketing
their product but we can stop spending
taxpayer money with incorrect um or
incomplete information about the product
they're trying to push um I just think
we're wasting a lot of money on a an
entire demographic of school children um
where this does not benefit them and in
fact there is an increased risk of
myocarditis that is no one can refute
that so um why are we risking our young
boys for a product that has very very
well
documented significant risk I mean
people may say it's rare but that why
risk it when the benefit um does not
outweigh the risk because there is
literally no benefit to the the vaccine
for children um I'm not sure if I
answered your question but I just um I
just wish that the messaging from DHHS
was complete that we do not recommend
this for people under 60 um or this is
not necessary talk to your provider
about your individual risk I'd be fine
with that message but because it's on
every gas station um pedestal or it's on
every side of a bus it's just we're
wasting we're wasting money and we could
use that money to actually improve
health outcomes right like that's what
we want to do we want everyone to be
stronger and healthier and uh use less
Services because they're living a
healthier life and the comorbity
comorbidities excuse me early on this
when this came out I thought for sure I
was a goner I have type 1 diabetes I'm
like well I'm going to die so I was
wearing a mask you know for six weeks I
was like guys we're going to like live
and we're going to put our groceries in
the sunshine and you know we're we're
going to do what what fouchy tells us to
do and then I realized this doesn't make
any sense you know and and so that was
my decision to do that and um I just I
feel like having a healthy body is our
best defense against everything and I
would argue that um those at the time of
covid who passed away with
covid um would have died from the flu
the year
prior okay or whatever virus so when you
have a weakened immune system and you
have all these complications any virus
can can make you ill this is what we
used to do back in the day we would say
oh when you're sick don't go around you
know the elderly or newborn babies you
don't want to give their your um virus
that doesn't really you know impact you
to them because they're
weaker so I just I mean I agree that
people with all of these conditions um
had a less of a chance of survival poor
outcomes needed help um because for some
people it really whacked them down um
you know I don't know a single person
and I've never heard of anyone who died
covid nobody was found dead at home with
covid so I don't I don't know if it was
the hospital protocols and the whole
system that did people in at the end I'm
not sure but it just if we had given
everyone like you said prophylactics and
like um a you know a little vitamin D
and um zinc and things like that like
India did maybe we would have all
protected ourselves a little bit more
from needing those services were told to
stay home to The Bitter End and then go
in when you couldn't breathe anymore
when what else can they do for
you it's just you know but again I guess
like we could all complain for for hours
and we've all done it at our dinner
tables about what has happened and how
we want to make sure it doesn't happen
again but what is the meaningful point
of this committee what can you guys do
so you don't feel like you've wasted
your Fridays here all Spring right like
what can come of this I would like to
see DHHS use our
money more conservatively like there's
no science to back up the money they're
spending on promoting it for children
and school's coming so all these kids
are going back for physicals um and
they're going to start school or or Camp
I just took my children for for a
physical exam they're getting these
visits and they're going to get okay
well do you want another covid shot and
I think it's annual for kids I don't
know exactly what they recommend now for
kids for people who are doing it but
it's just like can we just pause until
more information comes out plus there
more variants right and we're all
variant um quick question for you a
couple times you mentioned uh increased
risk of myocarditis for boys um do you
have access to that information that you
could send the committee I mean not any
more than anyone else does but um I I
assume it's been testified here before
we had so many more knowledgeable people
a couple weeks back but um to me that's
basic knowledge
I don't I don't know so I I'll find
something to send you but I'm yeah okay
yeah okay representative POA please all
right thank you very much any other
questions for represent
Phillips seeing none thank you very much
for being here apprciate you all again
uh does the committee need to take like
a 10-minute break or do we want to
continue on
more okay uh 10 minutes
okay quick T we'll come back at we'll
you
e
so TWY I'd just like to call us back in
um and I have a pin card here for Diane
uh please state your name and uh where
you're from and I'm Dian lechance I'm
from kukuk a village in hopkington New
Hampshire I guess you're not familiar
with the
kukuk
um I fully expected to come to a room
full of people like myself I'm here uh
to represent myself as a citizen I'm not
a representative or past
representative um I only found out about
this meeting few days
ago and um I shared it far and wide
because I knew there were a lot of
people out there who have a lot to say
and who were hurt uh badly by the
pandemic so again I fully expected the
room to be full and to arrive I had an
appointment I had to go to at 10 and I
figured I'd arrive with plenty of time
to make my notes um to speak and um you
know you might think uh maybe you should
have written your notes a few days ago
um
but I couldn't I opened up the
governor's um executive orders and the
anger in me Rose so high I wasn't sure I
was coming because I said can I afford
to be this angry
again and um I said you know if I just
deci to do this I'm going to open up you
know all of this again and I I really
think you need to consider that the
reason people aren't here are are
numerous one is
um that exactly what I said because what
I experienced in the pandemic I think I
have a right to be here and tell you but
it's so minor compared to what happened
to other people and what happened to me
never should have happened to anybody so
um um I know um one of the things that
gave me the courage to still come
because I saw nobody was here was um
she's not in the room now representative
was speaking at length uh and I was
listening in the car and she said I'm
not prepared I didn't know about the
meeting and I said well that's me and
then when I realized she was a past
legislator I thought well if she can get
up and just sort of find a way to be as
coherent as possible although being
unprepared then maybe they'll give me
the courage to do it so I have a lot of
random things to give also the other
thing I think that's hard is when you're
told you have three minutes and I
thought well I don't think they're going
to cut me off at three
minutes um so
um anyway
um so my first I know the legislator
that I spoke about she talked about
forums and I guess if I um I don't know
I have any suggestions about laws let me
tell you I just have no idea how law
works anymore and my son's a lawyer my
grandfather was a lawyer I don't know
how it works anymore so I applaud all of
you for staying in the fight and I
listen to that everybody speak and they
have really good ideas and it's because
you had the tenacity to sit and listen
to an awful lot that most of us you know
just we just can't do it so I appreciate
very much what you're doing and what you
continue to do because there has to be
an answer in all of this
um but she talked about forums and I
don't know if that's like to prevent the
next Fiasco that we've just experienced
or if it's to continue this
discussion um I think another reason
people aren't coming is that after what
they feel the government has done to
them it's a little hard to walk into
this building a little hard to walk into
the state house it's really I've
testified I'm a homeschooler for many I
was a homeschooler for many years and I
testified many times it took a lot of so
I have a little bit of experience that
probably helped me to get here there are
an awful lot of parents with young
children that they didn't even know they
had to fight for their rights I didn't
know I had to fight as a homeschooler
every single year for the right to not
take any money and be left alone that
was a big eye opener and now I see all
these young parents and I kind of get
upset that they're not speaking up and
I'm like they don't know they they don't
know and they don't know how and it's
all very intimidating so if I had a
suggestion it would be I don't know I
mean when my son was homeschooled was
supreme court on the road they went
places they went into communities and it
made it a little more welcoming they
didn't have to go to this you know
Supreme Court or the spirit court and
they they um you know it was in the
school you know I wonder how many people
might come out if you were at a school
in a community and said we want to hear
from you as a community and they might
feel safer in their school they might
actually feel a little bit like I can
remember what happened in these walls
and I don't ever want it to happen to
another child again so those I have that
to
offer but
um our story my story um is that
um I've worked for a pharmaceutical
company for 18 years as did my husband
and um very well acquainted with the
demeanor and the Behavior Uh um and the
expectations of the FDA when it comes to
the safety of drugs the the manufacturer
of drugs I worked in a facilities
and when we would get a notice that the
FDA had arrived because there's never
prior notice they're
here um you knew you had to be ready to
answer questions and you need to have
your ducks in a row and um it was
important it was important you were
making products that were going into
people's bodies and the people I worked
with took it seriously we took it
seriously one of the things I would have
done if I could have prepared um was to
actually get some clips for you from you
know or of the FDA approval meetings for
the
vaccine um I had the audacity to think I
was you know smart enough to go to the
meeting when they were making the
approvals the zoom meetings and I asked
other people that you're going and
they're like no how would I know and and
maybe they don't I you know I didn't
know most of what was being said at the
meetings um but I
did note that the demeanor and the
behavior of the FDA was not what I
recalled I don't want to say a lot
because I would prefer to show you clips
of and ask you is this how you would
expect an official from the FDA to
respond to some of what was said in
those
meetings um I've learned over the years
it's very hard to get people to
watch I'm not going to get anybody to
watch this when you put it out there for
us to view it's like very hard to get
people to sit and watch these uh
hearings and these meetings um but
they're very informative and
um I had concerns I have my own health
issues I I pay close attention to my
health and um
we decided early on that the evidence
wasn't there to feel comfortable taking
the
vaccine um a interesting note is I did
speak with my doctor and uh my husband
was with me and um my PCP and he said
that I had a 98% chance of surviving
covid if I caught it still thought I
should take the vaccine which surprised
me and I thought well okay but he didn't
push it and I I have to say I applauded
him and I continued to see seek his
advice on various
things um unrelated to co but during Co
I was seeking uh some care from
naturopathic doctor and I contacted
someone that was advised said someone
said she was really good and I T had to
talk on the phone before I went and I
advised her that I hadn't taken the
vaccine I wasn't interested what was
her um position on it she was right
there with me there's no reason blah
blah it's fine you're welcome you commit
in and I saw her twice and I can't
recall if it was the first or the second
visit they were only a month of pirate
visits uh
appointments um and they take a pretty
comprehensive history and um we talked
about everything and um it w and we
talked in a private room and it was all
well and good and then uh interestingly
in the hall on the way to pay my
bill she
said you need to get the covid vaccine
you're at high risk you you you're very
likely to be hospitalized if you get
Co and I was like so taken aback at the
unprofessional telling me on while we're
walking down the hall and we'd already
had a long conversation and when
her opinion of that changed I'm like why
wasn't that talked about maybe first
when we got to the appointment we had
this conversation before I took on you
took you on as a patient that really
rattled me that's what caused me to call
my PCP and say well maybe it's time to
talk to my doctor about what are my
risks so it's really interesting I think
and I'm just getting it out there for
what it's worth
um um I didn't get the I didn't get the
vaccine I did catch covid I was sick for
several days
um I probably have some things that
maybe is still residual some ringing in
my ears whatever but um I I fared pretty
well I don't think any of us I don't I
don't think I know I'll speak myself I
don't really know whe they're catching
Co you know for me personally was better
um if anything could have been better if
I took the vaccine I don't know anything
basically you know we don't we weren't
told anything everything was suppressed
the ability to have
conversations um with everyone the
people who agree agreed with where I was
going down the road and the people who
disagreed I I I didn't have that
opportunity because most of the people
who disagreed
just treated me poorly and said we can't
um may I ask a question sure So based on
what you just said do you think it
basically created like two classes of
citizens
um I guess I I want would want to
research the word class a little bit I
you know language is important um I
sides
um you know you know we we carried on we
we we followed what we were asked to do
by our our government we didn't agree
with all of it
um I do agree with people who say that
the governor took too many um uh
liberties with his P Powers um I may or
may be I may be right or may be wrong on
that but I will give you the one thing
that stood out for me
um and I felt probably bothered a lot of
people who won't speak up and that is
when the
governor um I don't believe it was
legally it was probably more part of his
casual comments that he made along with
his um uh legal documents that were
posted but
um my recollection and I heard it more
than once was that it's okay to go out
and drive if you are going to work
grocery shopping medical appointments
and
emergency other than that the only
people who really should be on the road
because you are a risk to are service
providers should you be in an accident
or need care um you put them at risk for
catching covid you just put them at risk
because we have a we have to deal with
it and um the only other people who
could go are people who we're going to
go and hike a
mountain or
exercise well I'm home with a stress
fracture in my
foot so I can't go hike I can't go walk
I'm cooped up in my house i' already
been cooked up you know I need to get
out of this house and go for a ride but
the governor just told me that I've
threatened you know people's lives
people's lives who I care about I care
about my emergency
responders I'm I also an intelligent
person I could say this makes no sense
this is
discriminatory if you're a healthy
person and you can hike a mountain or
walk on the beach you can go and drive
around but if you can't stay home home
chin up you know how many elderly people
do we know who can no longer move I see
them all the time I'm I'm right up in
that ballpark now go to the beach open
the window in the car you don't get out
and walk in the sand because yeah then
you'll need some emergency
services and um you just drive out into
the country and put some fresh air in
the wind you know in the in the car and
you go
home I started to feel like this is what
must be like to live in a country where
you know you you you have to carry
papers and you have to justify every
move because we go out and we'd
literally say so um we're going to hike
m whatever well madok right but when we
get there we're going to change our mind
you know to keep it right in our we say
this is sick when you have to come up
with scenarios to feel
okay about going out and taking care of
your own mental
health um that's a pretty sad State of
Affairs and our governor should really
rethink what he said um on that
represent
Belcher thank you madam chair and thank
you so much for coming out and
testifying today for us um and I'm
particularly glad to have you here given
your background um and dealings with the
FDA because I'd like to ask you to
respond to what I have seen just
recently which is some new information
that has come out now as I'm sure we're
all aware more and more information is
always coming out about things that
happen that we may not have known about
through various Freedom of Information
Act requests and the like uh recently a
Freedom of Information Act and this is I
think just within last week um at the
FDA uh received some internal emails uh
between some fairly high ranking
officials at the FDA regarding uh the
covid-19 um vaccines and citing
specifically the deaths of two young
people two minors um after the vaccine
who were found to have mild carditis and
they they unfortunately died um now the
the FDA officials were extraordinarily
concerned they were extraordinarily
concerned that if the public found out
about this they would reduce their
uptake of the
vaccine can you respond to as to whether
or not that that would be the primary
concern you would think of upon learning
something like that that two young
people had just died it's a little
disappointing to say the least that that
um you know 18 years I watched products
come down the pipeline and they made it
or they didn't make it it was a lot of
money
and I'd like to think and I do believe
the people I worked with had high
integrity and it's very easy to you know
there's always people who want to just
kind of skirt around the important
issues and
um I hope we call them all I know people
who lost their jobs because you know
honest people said no we don't we don't
do that we we're testing these drugs and
this is how it is we you don't do
anything in a lab by yourself everything
is witnessed don't ask me to witness
something you didn't I didn't witness I
mean I saw people
um lose their jobs and I was so happy
that they did because of the
Integrity um you know I I don't have the
facts I I I can only tell you what my
experience was and that's why I'm here
I'm here as a average citizen maybe with
a little more exposure to these things
do I know
everything no um but I think it's
important to listen to what listen to to
people and and then investigate that
maybe maybe there is data out there
but um I think we all know drugs have
been pulled off the market for a lot
less and drugs don't make it to the
reasons represent
leus can you go into a little more
detail as to the difference in demeanor
that you experienced with the FDA that
you were talking about
and do you actually have the clip
someplace that you could send us or not
I'd prefer not to because i' rather um
it was
my feelings when I looked at it and I
think it's it's more fair to everybody
to watch it and see it I would have to
research it that was the other thing I
would have to start researching I mean
at one point when I was we were going
through all this I kept some notes about
what I was learning and whatever it
became so difficult that you know to go
back and find it but I probably could
find it
um and and send that to you and then you
could watch it and um I could talk to
you about you know after we you if you
watch it and then I could you could ask
me I could ask you to look at a certain
minute marker and say well what about
that I mean there I believe if I recall
you know and then this recall what am I
recalling is um it just wasn't
professional and it was concerned it it
definitely concerned me I talked to
people about it um but people are afraid
they what do I do with that thank
you
um so for uh for us um my husband and I
decided that we we weren't comfortable
with the vaccine and we didn't get it
and my husband lost his job over it a
year and a half before retirement before
his plans to retire
um I really don't care to give out
personal information but it was a lot of
it's a lot of money you you you take
anybody you you can just take probably
find number of people lost their job
what's the salary ranges what are the
benefit ranges take that multiply by how
long it took them to find another job at
my husband's age was he going to find
another job there weren't a whole lot of
jobs in that and his his job required
that you show up at work um and um
on top of what we lost we had to pay for
medical insurance for a year and a
half and now with the economy and the
what's happening it's you know uncertain
you know we we're no different than
anybody else you know everybody's
uncertain is in this economy so I don't
cry too hard but it's real I mean I just
get tired of politicians just sort
of pushing it aside like it's minor it's
not minor
that was a lot of money in in in our in
our our
plans um in 2024 there's no such thing
as planning I don't think so you know I
have to sort of let that one go and be
grateful that we're we we're doing what
Penza so in the
last three years plus now
um I could probably we could talk for
hour about the stories that I have for
people that either one uh decided that
they weren't going to get the injection
um they tried they might have done a
medical exemption or a religious
exemption
um and they lost their job and then
there's a piece that decided that you
know they were going to even though they
were in a sense bullied and Chained and
all of that and decided that they were
because they had to provide for their
family and all those things one of them
that um was severely vaccine injured and
now he can't provide for his
family and and then the third piece is
they just decided to get out of whatever
they were doing all together and and go
do something different and um but I
don't you know that's the whole thing I
it's it should be a choice you know a
lot of people like to use you know my
body my choice and I I believe that 100%
um
so have you ever thought of going back
to because there's a that first category
that I told you that were either you
know denied an exemption denied their
their you know their right um whether
they're going to take something
experimental or not um you know body
bily autonomy to me is more than that
that means
everything um to go back to
um be restored fully I can give you a
lot of examples of lawsuits that are
that have been settled ones that are
currently in place in Massachusetts and
New York and all of that where for
example doctors and nurses and that are
they were offered their jobs back they
were offered back pay all of that kind
of stuff so I was just wondering if
you've looked down that pathway or not
some people were just really were so
abused and took it and um and it's
debilitating so having to fight is is or
having to think about the fight and a
lawyer and all those things is so
overwhelming that people don't so I was
wondering I raised that question um and
um to people who understand somewhat the
law of New Hampshire and um the response
I get is and you didn't mention that you
know anybody in New Hampshire has who
has actually won a case and the am I
wrong but is the uh Lauren New Hampshire
employees are at will and my husband
would be reminded that every single year
would get a letter with here's your pay
for the next year and reminding you you
are an employee at will and I don't feel
that you know with that in place that we
have a legal standing you know legal
ability
to go down that road and
you know it can take a lot of years off
your life to to deal with these things I
guess we don't have any confidence that
in the state of New Hampshire the way
the law is written that we even should
bother to start can I follow follow up I
hear what you're saying but that to me
it's a it's a constitutional issue uh so
I'm not just talking about the New
Hampshire Constitution which is so many
of our protective rights but our US
Constitution so a lot of these cases are
are based upon that and it doesn't
matter what specifically has happened
not you know in New Hampshire or not so
I'd love to you know see if we can TR
try to provide you some resources for
that um because I I think that I think
that that type of justice is especially
for folks that had
um you Decades of of work and
retirements and all of that it's it's
it's a imaginable unimaginable type of
level of kind of suffering for a family
so yeah I would welcome more resources
about it I you know it's I wasn't the
one who lost my job so um it's not a
decision I would make but um I mean I
might make the decision it's not mine to
make at this time so I did want to talk
a little bit about that in that um and I
don't know legally um what the legisl
can do but
um I believe the mandates were
discriminatory um I don't believe
anybody in the state employment was
required um I know people who have
contracts with the federal government
who were threatened with the possibility
that because they had a contract with
the federal government they would have
to but federal employees weren't allow
weren't mandated either and I find it
really interesting that some of the uh
family members of mine who are are in
the medical field were really
disappointed in me because they said
that if everybody gotten the vaccine um
we would have licked this right from the
start well it was a no-o from the
beginning if everybody wasn't required
to take it and they were going to give
religious exemptions and I found it
comical that these same people
um wouldn't be in a room with
me because I wasn't vaccinated but
they'd be in room with somebody who had
a religious
exemption from the
vaccine what's the difference I I just
it to me it to me that just added in my
um loss of trust in so many things
because to me that was just incredibly
hard and these are college educated
people who Felt This Way
um to me it we you know I said earlier I
don't know if we have classes of people
but we have different
sides and it became more of a political
statement than a statement on anybody's
risk to their life or their
health so um uh do you do you think the
conversation ended up really being about
what to do as opposed to being about
your
health I'm not sure what you mean so we
were told to take the vaccine to mask up
to social distancing to social distance
but we never really talked to about how
to take care of your health uh that
could be your physical health your
mental health um and other things that
we could do to build up our immune
systems um do you think that was
lacking um it was lacking in certain
areas I immediately sought that out um
and I do have
relatives um I have some relatives who
um in the medical field who wouldn't
have anything to do with me and others
who didn't like what they saw um and
they advised me they didn't agree with
everything that was happening um they
were caught up in it um and they early
on told me to take vitamin D told me
ways to take care of myself and I
started looking for those
resources Unfortunately they weren't
from my
government um should I expect them to be
from the government I don't know I mean
we all have to take care of ourselves
and I sought it out and I believe it
probably helped me tremendously if if
there was a silver lining in all of this
is that I have
taken large strides for my health and
learned a lot about my personal
health um I was wanted to share that
um we lost a lot of friends people we
thought were friends because we didn't
take the shot and family members Big
divides um I also experienced um I don't
know what to call it I I maybe it's
discrimination but it felt much deeper
than that at an eye
appointment um she the technician knew
that I had not had the shot I was never
shy about telling people I didn't want
people I want people to make their own
decisions and I was wearing the mask as
they required and but the behavior of
the person was really off the charts um
as I was putting my face into the eye
machine I was just trying to adjust the
mask to put my face and she literally
flipped out several times practicly
screaming at me not to take the mask
off and I'm like I was nowhere near
taking the mask
off and that happened two or three times
in the appointment and um I don't know
what to say about it you know you talk
about I talk people had so much more
injury to them but it's like I just
couldn't believe this was happening um
it was um difficult I left I felt like I
was slightly traumatized by it I I was
shaken by the person's fear and um
anyway do you think that the government
helped instilled that sense of fear into
the the
public
um I wouldn't say solely I would say the
media maybe even has a bigger part in it
um our government certainly in my
opinion could have made other decisions
um my father is gone he was born in 1925
and he taught his children never Panic
you know and I feel like our government
panicked my understanding and again I
could have done some research um is that
there was a plan in place for a pandemic
and it did not include many of the steps
we took closing schools mandating shots
all of this none of that was part of the
plan and it's really if I had a chief
complaint it's
why individual elected officials were
not allowed to stop and think for
themselves and to read those things and
question them um I would have hoped that
our governor would have done it I think
there's other governors in this country
who did and made decisions and I'm
disappointed that that didn't happen in
the Live Free or Die state
to be
honest so um representative
beler thank you madam chair and and
thank you again I just wanted to
backtrack for a moment to the um to help
clarify the issue around um around
employment and what happened to to your
family and and so many other people um
New Hampshire is in law it is a
employment at will or what you might
call that sort of State um
but the legal threshold for being able
to seek recompense for these sorts of
things that happened basically means
that you can be you can you can be fired
for no reason in New Hampshire but you
cannot be legally fired for a
discriminatory reason based on any sort
of protected
status um that provides an Avenue for
potential recourse the trouble trouble
the the difficulty would then be I'm not
currently aware of any Court precedent
that would provide an easy Avenue
meaning there is no there I'm not aware
of any Court decision at this point that
found that being fired for refusing to
take the vaccine for instance constitute
a discrimination although I am aware
that there are multiple lawsuits both um
at least at the federal level that are
ongoing I we do expect opinions Court
opinions on probably before too long so
just to clarify that whole issue a
little bit there is a potential Avenue
there um for people who feel they were
discriminated against um you can't just
be fired discriminatorily in New
Hampshire
um but realistically as of right now
anyway it would be an uphill battle
thank
you um I just want to see if I had
I think that's all um I would just
suggest what I said at the beginning is
um true is whatever has silenced people
throughout this pandemic is still
silencing many
and I don't know the answer to get more
people to come here and be willing to
speak I I feel like you know we lined up
and everybody stepped back and I was the
one standing forward I that's how I felt
Mikey who eats you know tries the Life
cereal I really guilt you know after
speaking up about the opportunity to
come here I um felt that I could not you
know not show up and um so I'm here um I
hope it doesn't end with this inquiry
because obvious vious ly the showing is
not maybe even what you hoped
for uh I'd like to really thank you uh
for being brave to come here and uh
being a voice to
let help us understand how people in the
public are hearing I know we're going to
hear from people on both sides as you
said there was basically two sides and I
really appreciate uh you coming out and
and and just add a little emphasis on um
you know my child was no longer in
school but you know I homeschooled and I
I was familiar with a lot of school
issues and I paid attention and I think
there's a awful lot of people out there
that would like to speak and probably
should be heard I hope it's not 10 years
before they feel safe to say anything
representative Penza yeah I just wanted
to speak to that um in regards with you
know people in the amounts here so um it
into um I always say we're in our own
Echo chamber right you know being here
in the legislature and stuff and um but
the the me you know your normal average
day person is not going you know typing
in New Hampshire general court and going
to look for hearings and stuff like that
it didn't get um I don't believe that
this is going to be the only time where
we're going to do this so and the next
time needs to be a more of a true press
release you know sometimes people don't
pick it up it wasn't picked up so I
don't I think we could fill rep's Hall
20 times over and I don't think that
that's going to be a problem I just
think today was our kind of first time
doing this um we were a little nervous
too and I don't believe that the message
truly got out there so there's a lot of
I I mean I just know personally there's
a lot of people that are willing to
speak and um and be heard there are a
lot that are in if they're in a field
that are silenced and stuff like that I
get that um especially if they're in
health care and things like that and the
fear of losing their jobs um but I think
it will be bigger and better the next
time um but it doesn't matter this was
enough today um and having you here is
truly a gift and I appreciate that so I
I wasn't publicized enough so I don't
want you to think that you know there's
nobody that's going to speak up because
I think that there are a lot that that
will and that will stand in solidarity
with you so just know that thank you
representative
leus yes you had mentioned that you had
gotten this out and contacted lots of
people Etc what was their response to
you uh one person said if they could
make it over from their job they would
come um they're considering coming I
said oh you probably could come after
work the place will be full and you know
don't have to miss out on work or make
it difficult um I don't I gave links to
the um streaming because the streaming
allowed you to be notified when the
meeting started which is always
convenient I can't tell you how many
things I've missed because I just
completely forgot what time it was so I
did give that to people so that they
could at least listen in I said try to
encourage them to listen in um medical
person said good you go take care of
that and I knew that was because they
didn't feel they could speak
oh thank you very much for coming thank
you for all you're doing I really
appreciate it thank you any other
questions
Smith Julie Smith from nashille here
thank you for the opportunity to vent
um I was actually at home earlier
and I knew about this event and I did my
Duty online and in social media and
stuff promoting it
um and unfortunately I didn't get the re
the the zealous response that I was
hoping for but I I felt like I did what
I could do
and I was expecting a full reps hul and
I saw that 6 hours were allotted 10 to
4:30 and I I know that elected officials
always get to speak first um God bless
them I know they have other things to do
and I'm okay with that so I was planning
on coming later and I was doing laundry
this morning and I saw that there was
like no one in the
background and sounded the alarm to
people you know on again the usual
social media groups hey hey where is
everybody and I was told to hurry on
down so that's why I hurried here but I
I want to say that
backup I and again like Betty gay used
the word Patchwork earlier I got a
patchwork of things and I'll try to be
coherent and my apologies in advance if
I'm kind of all over the place I think
being in a chronological order um my
personal Co story which is not
Sensational compared to various others
by any stretch of the imagination um I
the I was tuning in earlier and a member
had said this is public comment and it
kind of that that it's like it it kind
of stood up the hairs on my arms because
public comment in my city is is a an
event where disident and critics of the
ruling class they get um they get
insulted they get silenced they get
chilled um I know this this event I mean
this this hearing is about covid but now
rep beler mentioned Freedom of
Information which uh is synonymous with
right to know and this I got more to say
on that in a moment but I I'd like to
say that they go H that the
institution of um of the whole covid
thing and right to know kind of go hand
in hand and they're very intertwined in
nsha um and I want to touch on that
because we have we have a bunch of right
to know crap and I'll use the word crap
it how do I say
this with the hot mess that nashille is
it's a dumpster fire um with with with
right to know and people that criticize
the city they get insulted time is
limited at at public comment no matter
what the public comment is about they
get cut off and sometimes they get
interrupted and cut into and they can't
say I'd like to reclaim my time and then
afterwards the board of alderman any
member has unlimited time and they will
insult that person for more than three
minutes and then sometimes they'll
double team and triple team insult that
person it it it is um it's it's it's an
unfortunate drama show so I I've never
I've never spoken to the board of
alderman but I run I've run for Alderman
in fact um I chose to be my Alderman's
opponent this last fall because no he
didn't have an opponent and he had some
pretty de recent opponents and part of
my platform was never forget masks and
property taxes now I know property taxes
isn't within the purview of this
committee but we had the worst property
tax assault in in my history in the city
which has been since 1990 um and so that
you know my my anger against my
Alderman um had to do with those two
things and so one of my one of my big
signs that I uh um that I placed in the
city um said Alderman Dow voted twice to
mask
Nashua and I I'll get into that on the
timeline in a moment but when I was out
door knocking or campaigning lit
dropping talking to people you know most
of the voters most of the people I
interfaced with they really weren't
interested in talking about covid the
biggest the i i populated my business
card with uh five bullet points because
it was a it was originally going to be a
Vista Point a Vista Print template and I
had opposes government overreaching
covid mandates that was line number one
number two was opposes um irresponsible
spending and then my last point I needed
to fill in the box and I said Jersey
barriers on Main Street which comes out
of covid by the way and that I'll get on
get in on that later but while I'm out
talking to people out and about when
people looked at my business card and I
greeted myself as my my incumbent
Alderman's opponent the first thing that
it's like it was like a focal point
they're like oh yeah we don't want
Jersey barries on Main
Street it's like you go with it you meet
the customer where they're at in sales
and when you're campaigning you're
selling yourself as a candidate if they
don't want to talk about co uh and if
they don't want to talk about the budget
or right to know if they want to talk
about Jersey barriers hey I've made a
connection with them and they that came
out of covid and
actually Jersey barriers on Main Street
in ASA spawned out of City Hall's
response to covid and it turned into a
right to know with the art center and
I'm sure people are familiar with Lori
oano and again I'm I'm going out a
little I'm not staying in the lane of um
covid response at this point but again
they go hand inand it spawned out of
covid
and I I I'm quite convinced it's part of
this agenda 21 agenda 2030 and um who
was it Rah Emanuel saying never let a
crisis go to waste you know and and the
sad thing also is you know they say the
four boxes of Freedom you know you got
your soap box we've been censored in
ashaa you got your jury box we got judge
Temple and you know he's useless and um
you got your Ballot Box we've had two
City elections 2021 and 23 the ladder of
which I ran in myself and that one
included the mayor unlike Manchester we
only have an opportunity to get rid of
the mayor every four years and I I have
to say that um as nurse theres would say
all the time um Noah had to watch people
drown while he was building his ark well
Nasha is drowning in Kool-Aid and apathy
and quite frankly I'd like to move but
you know again for reasons outside the
purview of this committee I I I I feel
like I'm kind of stuck Sheltering in
place and so to to give the timeline you
know back in the very beginning like um
let's say around March of 2020 yeah I I
Ed hand sanitizers I kept six feet away
if someone wanted 7 ft that's fine um
you know M All For You know the
traditional you know don't share your
germs and Don't Go Near germs and all
that but then it's like when things were
being ramped up a notch and you'd have
Dr Chan and chib benett and the governor
and the deaf man and you know Adam sexon
and the uh 3:00 every day the
propaganda you
know people are being shut down right
and left and again it's kind of like
okay yeah I'm in my own little world
selfishly speaking I was one of the
fortunate people I worked in the com
warehouse and so Comcast is a household
name and people were going online and
what does Comcast Warehouse provide
modems and and and you got the the CEO
Brian Roberts saying he's going to give
$5 million you know in his uh like the
Bible would say announc with trumpets
like yeah look at me I'm giving $5
million to the underprivileged in
Philadelphia where Comcast Headquarters
is um so you know so those kids can go
to school online and and meanwhile
they're they're doing these wonky things
in in in operations and I I have free
speech to talk about it now because my
sance is long over um so I'm I'm not
chilled um at this point but I have to
say that these policies about like
quarantining equipment so a field
service person would come back and and
and and like okay you have to put it in
that box there and you can't box it up
and send it back we were hubbing spoke
warehouse and I was in a Spoke Ware I
was in a Spoke warehouse but we couldn't
send it back it had to be quarantined as
if it was a person or whatever like okay
and I'd cheat i' like seriously I the
Virgo in me would be like oh no I don't
want that one modem over there and the
truck is coming on Tuesdays and
Thursdays and I wanted out the door and
and then they would you
know bring in PPE like okay fine okay
fine and then then in
May early may they came out with the ask
policy at Comcast but it had some
interesting language and I was playing
my own lawyer I'm like oh well you know
it said something like well if you can't
be six feet away well you know 30,000
square sorry
um I did the math like 1500 1500 square
foot Warehouse I have my own workstation
my coworker does and I have my own phone
at the workstation and so does she so
like unless she said hey this is heavy I
need uplifting it we can stay six feet
apart and the security camera if anyone
was actually at the other end watching
um fine you know so I I never wore a
mask I never ever I I spent the last 10
months of my employment I'm proud to say
that I breathe fresh air but the toll it
took it's like if I had a full bladder I
would think I was in an industrial park
like okay um yeah you know I think I can
wait until I go
home um or I would like pre-plan not
having a second coffee and again this is
this is this was very real to me not
that you know it's a first world problem
people that are getting fired for not
rolling up their sleeve or their kid has
a school issue you know that those
things are obviously higher up um the
pecking order than whether or not I have
seconds on coffee but this is how mental
it made me um you know I I I would walk
to work cuz I live near work and um I
would take note of like where the ouses
were on the construction sites um
because I I couldn't go home to use my
own bathroom as a pedestrian and be back
in time but I was very obsessed with um
Escape Route like I am not going out in
the hall and leaving the warehouse
because the coast might not be clear I
knew who that the snitches were and so
again I I felt like as an essential
person and while all my friends and
their friends were being you know sent
home as non-essential no I never once
thought that we were all in it together
never once um I got Hazard pay for eight
weeks it was 25% raise I was
grateful um and I got I got you know the
someone earlier said papers please that
the the safety the the local safety
officer in the company gave us our Hall
Pass class ES and it was dated so if I
was walking on ammer Street to or from
work and someone said papers please not
that it ever came to that I had it
folded up in my wallet and
so um meanwhile so back to the we're not
all in this together I'm getting Hazard
pay I'm still getting a check I'm still
employed and other people were be their
businesses were being closed um and then
there were other people on the other end
the white collar workers oh they they're
getting a free they're they their
payroll was never interrupted never ever
interrupted you know they were sent home
they wereing their bathrobe at their
coffee table with their laptop barking
orders making policy and City Hall City
Hall never ever fured or fired anyone so
that that is correct so so these offices
it the city hall was like a fortress it
was by appointment
only and I had a neighbor my
neighborhood I like her um and so I I I
never wanted to create bad neighborly
relations so I bit my tongue but she
worked in a CA she worked for a
cafeteria company it was contracted with
NASA
schools and I'm like okay so now you
lost your biggest customer I'm like no
we didn't lose our biggest customer I'm
like Well everybody's at home online
learning um you're you're you're making
lunch like oh well the bus they didn't
Furlow any bus drivers they it's like
they they would make these lunches for
kids that have welfare lunch even though
they're at home in their own kitchen so
like the because they that Nash was so
big into this federal school lunch
program and so no no gym teachers
referal Lo no groundskeepers security
cafeteria workers whatever and this Co
this neighbor of mine again I didn't
want her to think I was uh you know not
happy that she was still employed but
you know I'm a taxpayer and you know on
goes the federal lunch and on go goes
the you know oh the library is having
box lunches during the summertime and
you know so that that
was that was like May then at the
towards the end of May they shoved local
mask Madness through it was like on a
Friday night Memorial Day weekend
and that's when I learned what a home
rule state was because you know there
was push back and you know I was pushing
back in my mind but I was not going to
City Hall and I was not talking to my
Alderman because I hate his guts but um
on social media I'm telling people yeah
I'm driving out to Hudson or to marac or
you know I I you know I I would I'm not
spending any money in the city and of
course I started getting insult insulted
online which is other people's free
speech to do to insult me like what do
you got against people keeping people
healthy and I I said that's not the
point that that that is not the point
it's government overreach well you're
killing my
grandma and it's kind of the same thing
as what was mentioned by the person who
spoke before me about hiking you know
PRI preco I was active in the hiking
Community also and people were shaming
people who were making plans to go
hiking up in the White Mountains like
okay you get sent home from school to
work and you're you want to go out in
fresh air oh no no you might fall and
hurt yourself and they might have to
call a litter team out and they're not
six feet apart and you're going to
burden that little tiny Hospital out and
the White Mountains and you know some
you know that and it's like the the
dominant mouthy um pushy people that
were talking that way
someone like a new person would come
online and ask a question about advice
I'd send them a private message I'd say
i' say hey um make your plans do it I
support you but I advise you not to
advertise it don't don't say your
intentions don't brag about it on Monday
morning go ahead and do it but this is
the
hostility so the m m mask Madness comes
out and then throughout the summer so
that was May now you're get getting into
like
July and now there's no there's no
imposed mask Madness in the suburbs but
now Market Basket decides to come out
with it like oh oh that's a real bummer
that's my favorite place to shop it's
the cheapest or whatever and um I can't
go to Hudson anymore it's all of Market
Basket I'll go to Shaws I don't like
them they're expensive but okay and then
they did it too so then Haniford was the
last hold out until sept M so I was
crossing the bridge out to Hudson and
going up 102 for
Haniford and they did it too and I was
thinking wait a minute
okay if they people talk about private
businesses can do what they want and of
course the the the the
opposition was saying well well you know
that's the private business they can do
what they want I felt like it was a a
Consortium you have the three major
competitions the three Market basket
Shaws and Haniford
together they they they they they
collectively as a threesome saw to it
that nobody was going to get a 99 get
get half and half for 99 cents a qut to
put creaming their coffee I'm just using
a a petty example but they they saw to
it that if you want to you have to go
outside Society you have to pay General
store price if you want to perform
Commerce whether whether it's a loaf of
bread container milk stick or butter
whatever and not wear mask and so I'm
out in the Upper Hills of Amherst and
going to these expensive places to buy
little
things and um getting drive-thru because
they're not going to you know it's like
I I'd never been told by a drive-thru
clerk that they wouldn't like take my
money if I didn't wear a mask and I've
ordered a lot of meal kits it's not the
diet that wanted and um you know as a
member of overweight America it's not
the diet that's right for me but um I I
I was not going to participate in mask
Madness and so that was in the summer
then now you got primary coming up and I
was a candidate my my reps or at least
two of them the ones that are still in
office today they joined with I don't
know how many other reps on May 28th of
2020 they made a letter to the governor
demanding that he muzzle the whole state
and um I know one member of this
committee who is married to a rep would
know who my reps are because they're
married to each other um I know you're
not supposed to say names but um they
demanded it and I ran against them I ran
against them and so I had primary coming
up and I had the utmost anxiety because
I was a firsttime candidate
and as first-time candidate I don't want
to do anything to draw attention to
myself such as fighting with the
election staff about um you know
fighting about masks
and I had so much anxiety that I
considered compromising my personal
principles I despise absentee voting I
despise it unless you are active duty
military or bedridden I this the I I
just totally disapprove of absentee
voting but I was considering it I was
really considering it because I felt
like I was being bullied chilled
suppressed and interestingly County
attorney was a a um an office that had a
primary
and one of the one of the um
candidates um the one that didn't win
the primary and later became a rep and
later resigned uh resigned this calendar
year
he wrote a granite grock article called
voter
suppression and it talked about if I
catch that and I become County
attorney consider your consider every
election official on notice and that's
why I voted for him because and I
printed up I printed up the granic grck
article and and put it in my pocketbook
in case I was given if I I was given a
hard time by the election staff at
Charlotte School I was ready it was kind
of like my papers
and interestingly nothing happened at
the primary but then there was the
election right behind it in
November and because it was a
presidential
election that there was a line outside
the school um quarter 5 in the morning
it's the earliest I've ever shown up to
vote and it was the longest line to date
at that in my
experience and so I'm in line I'm the
only one breathing fresh air and I am
sip I'm I'm like nursing that Dunkin
Donuts coffee as my like people talk
about on airplanes you know like okay
I'm having a coffee I I'm not you know
tell me to wear a mask I'm sipping my
coffee and so 6 o'clock they you know
they they let everyone in and I'm just
kind of like pretending I don't know I'm
pretending I don't know that I'm I'm I'm
the black sheep you know and I hear
excuse me excuse me I knew they're
talking to me I knew I I knew it was me
but I played stupid excuse me and
finally this guy got right in my face
you're not wearing a mask no no I'm not
I'm like oh well you know you're going
to have you know
like um I looked at him I'm going to
have to go get the moderator now this is
where it became interesting um I I don't
want to identify myself as a candidate
not only to not draw attention to myself
in a negative way but I don't want to
get accused of election heing hi I'm the
rep candidate a rep candidate so the
moderator who I did not know at that
time she comes you know she approaches
me and she's like oh are you willing to
wear a mask no I'm not and she's like
okay um and when she turned I saw her
name tag and she had like some long
unspell last name
and from being a rep candidate and
having the walk books I door knocked her
husband and he let me put he let me put
my sign in their
yard and long story short there was a
Congressional candidate that was in the
Air Force with this guy so when I saw
her name I knew I knew that my ballot
would get put into the machine but let
me tell you if it was any other ward in
Nash or any other place How would how
would my fellow voters voting the same
way know that their ballot there there
were stories from other commit other
communities where they would set up like
a a popup camping canopy and then like
have this box or whatever and people
were sharing on social media like oh
this is this town and this is that town
it it's kind of like um it was like Jim
Crow in the bubbler the water fountain
or something like you know um
and I was like well I know my Ball's
getting counted but that that doesn't do
anything for anyone else and question
okay represented Penza yeah I'm very
familiar with the there definitely was a
they created a a two class voter um
system when it came to folks in in
several towns not necessarily where you
were voting in that Ward but um yeah
there was a lot of that that I was very
familiar with one was in Bedford for
example
um so did you hear um specifically about
any you know voters that felt that they
that their ballots weren't um counted
from being not wanting to have wear a
mask uh yes yes I did um I I I do not
have specific names in towns not that I
kept a journal of it but there there was
talk E online and just through the
grapevine that people were concerned
that they were being suppressed and and
it how do I say this it stands to reason
that such people are voting for the same
slate or slate customized to their
Community down to their Senate and rep
District so it it is voter suppression
and Bedford you did mention Bedford
Bedford was the the um where the person
who
educated me that Nash is not a home rule
election that was Election Day November
and we had a governor that said oh no
I'm not going to be like Charlie Baker
we don't need to uh you know we don't
need to mass the state no no no no no
okay
so Tom lanzara is the only one that gets
elected out of 27 rep seats in
so trying to think of the anyways if you
go up and down the
ballot
um the governor was one of the lucky few
that got
elected and so he gets he gets reelected
and then on November
19th just a matter of a couple weeks
after getting reelected tell on the
campaign Trail saying that he won't he
does he unleashes the mask the The Mask
Madness for the whole state and now that
want that that brings me to the whole
topic of censorship and silencing people
um everybody knows Frank Staples he's
famous famous Frank and and and and he's
not allowed to he's not allowed to pick
it outside the governor's mansion on
public property in a
culdesac they're out there with pickets
they're peaceful picketing peaceful
but um you know the the the the the
selectman brother of the governor
silences they they force through without
the due process of making a town
ordinance called like picketing in
residential area and a journalist
Christopher maidment who um I think he
was working for New Hampshire Journal at
the time he had his credentials on him
and the police they cited him and
charged them also with um with that so
that's that's one example of the
censorship um I had something else down
here um Dr nass who um a Betty gay
mentioned earlier when when she was she
she forgot her name when she was talking
a few hours ago when I was watching the
live stream Dr Ness um look what
happened to her and and just the mention
of her
so two years ago and it was April 6 2022
when um the the the the senate committee
chair was stuck at a Florida airport and
the vice chair was chairing a series of
hearings for bills and and and and and
and and and then rep rep betay was at
the mic talking about Dr nass and
suddenly the vice chair cut in and
silenced it's on YouTube he silenced her
he said well we don't need to hear those
names
and I can't I can't unhear it it was
just
um question yeah do you feel like there
was censorship in New Hampshire yes okay
representative Belcher thank you madam
chair I just wanted to because I an
interesting idea kind of came into my
mind regarding the issue of picketing
and protesting uh the government actions
during that time you mentioned that
people were cited and arrested and
otherwise uh for for picking protesting
um in front of the Governor's
home but this was a weird time because
most things were shut down do you
remember do you remember at that time
was the government the governor and
other people were they working no the
state house was closed it was reopen the
State House reopen the state house and I
remember an cop repel at the time had an
appointment to get sworn in because she
missed the organization day and she had
an appointment and security wouldn't let
her in so interestingly I guess my
question then is it could be
phrased people were picketing and
protesting the governor at his home but
could it not also be phrased people were
picketed and arrested for protesting the
governor at his place of work yes thank
you that's a that's a that's that's a
very important point and I I agree you
you are right
and um yes I I was going to add that um
there's been protests on the sidewalks
in front of the homes of 49 other
Governors so why is New Hampshire
special and and I want to add to that so
this
silencing okay private sector silence
and Chris AER he's he's not an elected
is not a public elected official but now
we're into the spring of
2021 and my job ended I took early
retirement which was for
reason well let's say the end of my my
employment with Comcast came to an end
and I left on good terms so now I am
newly unemployed or faux retired because
I'm not 59 and a half and so I have free
time and the the uh Nash GOP chair said
hey we could use some help uh in the
suburbs because the the seat vacated by
the unfortunate untimely death of
Speaker hinch is going to um result in a
special election in in marac and
so I'm outside of the church one of
three polling sites in marac um and I'm
there I'm there with um Steve negron's
wife rep Morin Mooney and I'm being
introduced to all these big wigs because
it's a special election so stepanick and
Chris AER who I've never met before but
I saw Chris on the news being harassed
in DC by some hecklers
so I kind of I knew who he was visually
could you tell us who you know who he is
exactly I mean so so Chris Egger is the
is the GOP chair of New Hampshire is
that his correct title and it was okay
so that was his title in in in April of
2021 at the time of the marac special
election for the seat that now is
occupied by Bill Boyd um so I get
introduced Moren Mooney introduced me to
Chris
ger
and there was a discussion about how our
governor would veto a standalone bill
against I think it was critical race
theory that and that he because he told
the press that it's against free speech
for the teachers and I said to Chris AER
well what about the free speech of Frank
Staples and the pickers outside the
governor's man
on public property and he looked at me
it was like the dirtiest stink eye I've
ever received like how dare you that's
not what polite Society does now again
he is not a public
servant but he he made it very clear
that that was unacceptable to think that
way a republican the highest highest
ranking member of the Republican party
is is telling me how dare you support
picketing outside the governor's mansion
so that I wanted to note on that that
this silencing and censorship it it it
was it was um
then the um a little while later it was
April 16th actually um
so after the marac
election um The Mask tyranny expired and
I don't know what made our governor
decide not to renew it but I was elated
and and and and I was not alone in
thinking don't anyone thank him you do
not thank your Tyrant for giving you
your freedom back that's Stockholm
syndrome but that that's that's what he
did and so that was a Ro and then now
people start talking about the vaccine
it was kind of getting in the news and
building a head of steem and I'm not I'm
unemployed so I I'm not worried about
being forc vax but at the at that time I
was taking advantage of free
outplacement services that was part of
my parachute package in leaving
Comcast so I I was at Comcast for 20
years and so my resume was like on some
AOL saved site you know it was anti an
equated so I took advantage of like how
to make a new resume to learn what an
elevator speech is and what a a public
exit statement is and how to interview
and how to network and so I had a few
telec calls with the counselor and I
always wanted to know how to address
mask policy but I didn't it's kind of
like when you're a kid and you're told
well don't ask about the break policy or
the lunch policy or the pay policy you
know you're not supposed to come off as
petty you're supposed to like ask how
the company's doing and what your
Future's like and it it's like you're in
Charmed school and so I did not know how
to broach the subject of mask policy so
I just decided to not look for work and
I I know that's a unusual and it's not a
practical way of handling a situation
but I don't have kids I don't have a
morgage or a car payment so I I was in a
fortunate position to just kind of like
put it all in the meanwhile people are
talking about the
jab and so over the summer you're
hearing more and more people there being
fired or threatened to be fired and I
think um I think we have a purity right
now uh in attendance uh this committee
that the people in attendance I I I feel
there's some there's some intellectual
Purity here um as far as
agreement about medical freedom and so I
don't need to tell you what happened you
know there was the Dartmouth there was
the conquered Hospital there was St A's
the executive counil the arrests and
nurse theres you all know that and that
you know I'm guessing you can consider
that already history and on
record um
so I just have to say that
elections you know I ran for rep twice I
ran for Alderman last year um and and I
don't it's it's not about whether or not
voters in W two like me like me
meaning think favorably of me uh they
won't even come out to vote for a new
mayor
um elections are not and elections are
not secure and I'm I going to say that
even though that's not the purview of
this committee so again the four boxes
of Freedom problem things aren't being
solved in the court and you could say
that about a right to know
um I wanted to do I W I didn't know how
to do a right to know and I wanted I
wanted to know all these ties that other
people people with Minds greater than
mine investigatively speaking people in
schools that are saying oh we can't let
the mask drop because of money coming in
and I I you look like you have a
question but I just have to say before
you ask the question that there was only
one member of the school board that I
voted for and she was ousted in a
recount last last last election and and
in and the chair of the school board
called the police on her um couple years
ago I don't have the date and then she
became a rep in Ward one herself and his
on children and family law and she she
told when on national TV that she felt
threatened by domestic terrorists so
that's the world that Nashua
is represent beler thank you madam chair
I just wanted to jump in real quick
because you had mentioned about
this committee understanding uh a number
of things and they're already part of
the record part of history but the way
this committee
operates um is we are we are collecting
uh documents and testimony and making it
part of a permanent record that will be
a part of this um committee and and may
or may not wind up in a report at the
end but if there is specific items some
of the things that you had mentioned
that you want to be considered uh as a
part of a permanent record you can email
any documents you want to this community
and they'll become part of our permanent
record okay representative Penza yeah so
just to follow up on that there's um
because the committee does you know the
committee is five is 10 large if
everybody's here and um and for those
documents to be part of that permanent
record it would it would be helpful a
lot of these things that you you know
made mention to even um even specific
things about nashwa
and mask ordinance and all of that was
all public record uh um there's news
stories about it new stories about with
executive Council hearings so it would
be wonderful if you you know you could
you could put that in a document just so
that that's all in the permanent record
as well about you know have them as you
could have them as a attached as a PDF
if you wanted to not just a link um you
know it would be helpful just in kind of
like your timeline with all those
different things that kind of took place
um there was a lot of stuff that took
place in nashwa specifically in in
regards to um The Mask mandates it was
um I have a friend that uh owns a
business and I'm not going to out him
and it was very difficult for him um to
balance what he was doing so you know
cuz um he wanted people to be able to
have that freedom but he also didn't
want his business to be shut down so it
was um it was really difficult for a lot
of people to navigate that space and so
any information that you have I would
love you to to document I'd be willing
to work with you and put you know
whatever way you'd like that presented
but I want to thank you for reminding me
a couple things I forgot to mention we
had mask Madness 2.0 so in the fall of
2021 they shoved in like a like a
emergency board of alderman meeting and
mask Madness 2.0 went from November
until February and they renewed it twice
and so you know was from November until
February and the other thing was that um
I had the same dentist for 30 years or
almost 30 years and when mad Mas when
mask Madness expired the fir 1.0 which
was like I I I 13 months so it was like
um I I called the office I said I
understand that you know I canceled my
appointment and I have to be at the
bottom of the wait list um but I do see
that uh City Hall you know I what
happened in City Hall the other night
and I just want to know if if I can have
an ordinary um office visit oh what do
you mean like well I don't mean to be I
I know that your job is to answer the
phone and and that you don't make policy
but um you know oh you know like oh it's
still um masks or I forget what she said
but again I don't want to come off as
like trolling her I'm like you mean
masks for the dentist and his staff or
do you mean patients in the waiting room
everyone like oh okay well um thank you
for answering my question and I fired I
fired him um it was all about the the
dental Society Association it wasn't
about City Hall anymore but the other
thing was regarding businesses we had a
business there was a business called wab
bagel and w Bagel was
um a a a nsha native who was a marine
veteran he was in the
Marines and came home from the Marines
and opened wet a bagel and he refused to
comply with mask Madness at and and
there was another business in Bedford
called Simply Delicious they're still
open um so the two of them they were
harassed by the Attorney General's
office and there's a there's a granite
rock m material on that but um they they
quietly dropped the charges against both
of these businesses and and in the and
I'm sad to say that wab Bagel is no
longer in business he decided not to
renew his lease when his lease was up
he's like you know I'm out of here and
um you know um that's too
bad when you say he they were harassed
by the Attorney General's office what do
you mean oh threats letters you're in
violation um I I have to say for the
record though I I did I I did not read
all the communications and I wasn't
there but
um
he they they received a lot of unwanted
attention let's just put it that way and
um it was what a bagel and is it owned
by a it's a family business a veteran
owned family business and the family
any other
questions well I will state that I
can understand the papers I was given a
paper also to carry in my vehicle uh in
case I got
stopped um which is
crazy um
so well thank you thank you I hope I
hope I was helpful I want I I should say
as a Harding comment that I I do want to
emphasize what I think a couple other
private citizens said you know hey I
didn't have it as bad I did not have
kids I I don't have kids so I didn't
have kids in the school I did not get
fired um you know I got the usual um
rude treatment and i' I lost friends and
I was unfriended on Facebook and you
know it so a lot of it was really
internal and how I was how I felt dayto
day but um I I feel like I was one of
the more fortunate nsha people so do you
feel like
um this pandemic and the response to it
created like some mental health uh
anguish for a lot of people oh most
definitely most definitely and and and
again I'm not a parent but I I just I
hear stories about what it's done to
people's kids
and so much that like you know um
I'm there for I'm there for HB 1093 and
and and and I was there for HB 1131
which was VTO two years ago um you know
kids are the future and these are our
future caregivers our future government
officials are our future doctors our
future media people um so this this um
abusing a whole
cohort is is going to have um Fallout
come thank you so much for coming to
discuss represent
blus and she was talking about the
things we all know question is do we
have any of that recorded as part of the
committee we all know it we all remember
record so I I think um what we need is
and I think we've received well from HHS
uh DHHS the co timeline and I believe uh
representative beler put a lot of that
stuff already into our record including
a lot of of the emergency orders have
been printed out in part of our file um
but if anyone can think of anything else
that may needed to be added I think
Penza yes so I believe that um and there
was more than just those businesses
there were there were several and then
the
legislature um passed a bill to remember
that to okay I wasn't in at the time so
I do remember that I think all of those
things the businesses that were affected
notices that went out from um the
Attorney General's office because I I
saw one that my girlfriend got in
Portsmouth so I'm familiar with these
and they were um you know threats of of
closure and fines um I believe that
every single one of the businesses that
received that every single notice that's
should all be public record um and then
when after that bill passed how it was
just kind of all cleared away um I think
all of those things um need to be in in
our in our permanent record so I will
make sure uh I have some a friend that
could possibly do that but if they don't
then I'll make sure I gather all those
materials I also think it's important
because to for us
to just because you know it was all kind
of cleared away through uh through a
bill um
if 90% of those businesses aren't open
anymore look at the damage of what we of
what was done so I I think all of those
need to be there to say um to be able to
say okay well we need to make sure we
don't ever do something like this again
so um if there's any documents or
anything uh one of the easiest way
especially if you get the information
online is to email the entire committee
uh that way it'll go to our uh assistant
and can be put into the permanent record
the other thing she was talking about
was the
individual um
City
mandates and I do remember I had
forgotten but I remember that we wanted
to go a group of us wanted to meet in
nsha oh a group of us wanted to meet in
Nashua and go out to a restaurant and
then the whole issue with oh we're
walking outside near nobody else but we
had to put masks on and it was well we
kind of stopped going out to eat in
Nashua but I I had forgotten about that
until she said it and so the question is
what was the patchwork of
mandates and I as I recall the only
cities who could do mandates or their
own
health recommenda you know laws were um
ones that had a health person as part of
the city so like my town couldn't but
NASA could so it would be nice to have a
record of what was that
Patchwork and who you know right so I
can tell you that um we do have have
what we call self- inspecting cities and
they would be able to do their own uh
Homestead rule laws and everything else
but because they're self- inspecting
towns or cities or municipalities they
get to set their own guidelines which
could be more stringent than the state
can't be less stringent but can be more
stringent I get that I was just
wondering if we had any kind of record
of what they did come up with what what
was the
patchwork like nashaa and their Mass
mandates when which nobody else had to
do right I mean I
I think that's I think that's would be
an interesting Avenue to go down but
because we're really looking at the
state as a whole I mean we can put that
look see if someone can get that data
for us
um but I think our perview is more
overall um the represent
Belcher thank you madam chair and we had
just briefly discussed based on some of
the testimony we've heard today it it
might be useful to um as a committee
perhaps submit an information request
freedom of uh uh what is it called 91a
type request to any relevant um New
Hampshire executive agencies that would
have issued um warnings citations
anything of that effect um to businesses
within the state uh regarding any of
these things I think the B most of that
would fall under the purview of the
Attorney General but representative wey
it would be uh since we've discussed
about the closure of businesses and and
the loss of
businesses uh from not being able to
recover from the economic hardship that
those closures caused it would be good
to get perhaps some statistics on the
change in small businesses across the
chronology of the uh pandemic because
then I think you know we're since that's
one of the things that we're
looking at across the state of New
Hampshire it'd be good for us to have a
better understanding of of that impact
it's it's uh you know tangential to some
extent it's tangential because um it's
not directly affecting Health per se but
you know or the health of individuals
and I think that's probably often our
our primary focus but I think if we're
looking at the widespread a
impact of it that that that has a you
know just as we've talked about the
children suffering from um ongoing
effects of covid and how it impacted
their learning abilities and has
derailed their education to some impact
to some degree because of the impact of
wearing masks and not being able to
learn speech and things like that I
think there's also a impact due due to
the the closures of small businesses
that have never recovered and um you
know New Hampshire has a huge amount of
small businesses so this would be this
would be a good thing to understand
because um that's something that we need
to protect we're lucky that we have a
good um relatively speaking to other
states anyway a good economic
environment but we need to make sure
that we don't do things that would
threaten that um if we if we encounter a
pandemic again right I I just want to
remind us I'm just going to read this
really quick that our areas of
particular Focus are on the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and the
implementation of the emergency use
authorization uh vaccine efforts um so I
am wondering how much
of the rules that some of these self-
inspecting towns I think used Federal
guidance instead of State guidance for
and I guess that is really would be
under our
perview because the state not
necessarily imposed all of it
but because of federal guidance as we
have heard regarding the education
sphere with schools even though the
Department of Education said people
could go back to school
they opted to use federal guidance so
represent weary uh yeah thank you I
think that that's really important and
and I mean one of the great Hallmarks of
the United States is the fact that we
are 50
experiments and um when people undermine
the experiment that is New Hampshire by
not um as we've seen when those were
imposed in other states that were more
restrictive than New
Hampshire
um we're we're we're no longer
participating in that great experiment
and we're causing our our uh citizens in
New Hampshire to suffer under the the
restrictions that are being placed
elsewhere I mean there are some states
that we all know of that were horrific
in how they handled this so I mean to
understand that aspect is going to be
very
important represent
Penza so to follow up on what
representative weary had said I think
it's I and we do have a lot of this
information um
so I'm very familiar you guys might not
be with the it's called gopher and it's
the um it's called the the governor's
office for emergency relief and Recovery
I'm going to interrupt you right now we
are next Friday going to be hearing from
commissioner Caswell who is the person
who was in charge of all those funds
perfect and he's still in place
currently he is yes so so just so you
know he will be here so if there's
anything specific that you would like
him to ask him if you could email so he
can prepare that would be wonderful so
he can be prepared to answer some of the
questions so we can decide if um maybe
we put some of these questions in
advance but the documents that I know um
some of it will be from gopher um and
some of it will just be um through other
different you know either state or
executive a you know agencies or
whatever but I think it's very important
for us to be able to find that
information um you know we find out of
course who was affected specifically um
by the pandemic who is no longer in
business um we can get that information
as well um and then who received of
course uh you know cares act money which
is through gopher um we can see that I I
want all of that information I think we
could get that in advance I'm going to
interrupt you for a moment represent but
let me I'm going to send give you a list
these are questions that have already
been sent to him just so you know so uh
he's already been sent um the following
uh from the standpoint of covid related
federal funds I.E car's act and ARA what
was the timeline for receipt from the
federal government and what and by the
state what was the decision-making
process for distribution by state and by
whom how much money was received and
then
disseminated to whom was it distributed
by the state are you tracking the use of
funds would you say they have been
successfully deployed
uh are there measures of success how are
we doing those are some of the questions
that have already been forwarded to him
those are the questions have already
been forwarded to commissioner Caswell
in uh preparation of next Friday's
meeting so if there's anything else on
top of that I didn't mean to interrupt
you but because these questions have
already been sent to him I just wanted
to give you uh as opposed to duplic
duplicative efforts no I think that
sounds pretty good I think the only
piece then would be you know businesses
that you know we could get some
information I would like to see kind of
like well now it's 2024 now and I'd like
to see kind of like where we're at I
mean um in regards with cl there's been
a lot of anecdotal information I'd like
to really see the numbers of you know um
of what's happening in regards with
weary so uh you never get money without
strings attached so it would be it would
be interesting to
ask
what what did the federal government
require when providing that
money and whether or
not that you know what what sort of
obligations were coming we have a
visitor that wasp has been trying to get
so I think um so I think I'm not sure
it could be brought up during the
discussion and and provided as a
followup but it be it might be good to
know were there any federal government
requirements being made because of the
distribution of money not just you know
it
was not just a charity if you will but
but we were then obligating New
Hampshire to meet certain conditions and
if so what were those conditions I I
think the question what was the
decision- making process for
distribution by the state and by whom
would kind of go into that a little bit
I mean um so but if like I said if
there's any further questions or
anything more specific just email me um
and we'll get that out but I just wanted
to let everyone know that we are meeting
next Thursday May 16th at 10:00 a.m. we
will have someone here talking about
vaccine mandates
um from the federal level uh regarding
uh the emergency use
authorization uh his the speaker is
named Aaron Siri for anyone who's
interested we will then be meeting again
on
Thursday I mean that's excuse me that's
Thursday May 16th and then we'll be
getting meeting again on Friday May 17th
I do have it slated for a 10:00 a.m.
start uh commissioner casual will be
here at 2: p.m. um I was hoping to hear
back from director buckton from Homeland
Security to see if he was available in
the morning if not um I don't know I can
open it up um for for uh folks to come
in again uh I know that there were a
couple people uh I know there were two
State reps that wanted to
testify um today and um maybe they can
come next uh Friday Friday morning to
speak with us um so I wouldn't ask uh
for them uh to be available um if I do
not hear back and I can send out an
email to them but I just wanted to give
everyone I apologize for backtack
meetings um but the speaker on the 16th
was already scheduled before I heard
from commissioner Caswell and we've been
trying to meet with him and I did not
want to uh change or affect um that
meeting at all because I think it's
extremely important uh we will not meet
the following week I think we're going
to have a busy week uh especially with
session it'll be the week of the 23
right the 23rd 24th correct yes that's
the one time I can make so we will not
be meeting uh that week at all um but
anyways everyone uh representative warry
just uh one last thing I know our our
speaker from
kuk um recommend Ed going to the
community to hear public
testimony um I know that presents its
challenges but um is that something that
um you know maybe this is a rhetorical
question right now but is that something
that can be considered
so uh I would have to speak talk with
the speaker's office I don't know if
that's I mean that's something executive
Council does I don't know if that's
something that this committee would
would be willing to do I would have to
check with all members and logistically
it could be a little bit of a uh present
an issue because they have to be live
streamed and recorded so um I don't know
how realistic that is but the fact that
we have had now uh a few people from the
public come out and testify uh maybe it
will give other people um you know
courage as we go on so um with that
being said uh if there's nothing further
I would like to note that we will be
adjourned until and our next meeting
will be May 16th at 10:00 a.m. thank you